today the guest on our podcast is one of
my favorite people
on the planet bridget fedesi watkins
welcome is one of her podcasts she
interviews legends in a in
in a way that actually
it's very rare that i'm impressed by an
interviewer because i'm like i've heard
this person be interviewed by a million
people they always ask the same
questions this bitch doesn't and
dumpster fire with bridget fedesy is
easily my favorite news program
so where to god
it is the only thing that fucking makes
me laugh and uh i
had to ask her if i could go on it um
also uh go to her um i'm actually you're
gonna see in this podcast me wearing
some of her merch which i love um
bridgette fantasy it's a wildly insane
last name and she has an insane last
name what is your last name uh it's
irish
no i made that word out i think part of
the reason i haven't been friends with
you sooner is because i didn't know how
to pronounce your last name
and i was like i can't take this on i
just learned how to say chameleon i was
saying
until last month it's a word i made up
is it yeah what yeah that is so
aggressive
well what's your last name
are you running from the law no no no i
just i'm not i don't want to say it like
publicly because i don't have to anymore
but um
no i made my i made that word up for my
company god because it doesn't make any
sense people are like is it greek i'm
like no it's just a word i made up i
made it up for my company is this from
troy are you from troy
i made it up for my company it was just
a word that meant when reality becomes
parody or parody becomes reality this
made no sense in 2006 it makes a lot
more sense now
and then because of social media was
this was like the dawn of social media i
wanted people to know the word and i
didn't want to put my real name up
because
i didn't trust social media so i just
used bridget fedesy and then i was
teaching yoga and working with autistic
kids when i started doing stand-up
comedy and so i took it as my stage name
for like stand-up comedy because you
were hanging out with comedians well
sometimes you were working with autistic
kids
every night of the comedy
since i was already um using it online
and then it just stuck i mean it's still
a weird thing where when people
introduce me i'm like who's that bitch
and i'm like oh it's me
but okay so fantasy is
fantasy comes from fantasy
p-h-a-n-t-a-s-y
it's kind of like fantasy and
it's like fantasy and fetish combined a
little bit but it was just it was just
that i made up and
is your is your specialty called fan uh
fascinating pha
i'm obsessed with this but we do call
like in my
i have a little subscriber community at
fantasy.com and it's like
that we call it the fam with a ph
this is f i didn't know that yeah oh
yeah and then i always start with this
podcast with um asking the um guest if
we're friends and they get to answer
yeah
we are friends we are now but we
our first friend date was i heard you on
rogan after being scared of you for
years
um so weird for to hear well nothing
scared me more than someone i mean an
independent content creator who was like
i fucking am just gonna say what i'm
gonna say and i see you as like this
fearless comedian who's afraid of
nothing so i i don't know why that just
is
it's funny to me that that would be
something every time i post an instagram
like will bill burr like this i'm like
he's my friend
like it's just like
you know it's so will this make my dead
dad approve of me like i am just run by
fear in a way that i constantly have to
like but um but i did
after saggett died there's something
that does happen when
a horrible thing happens where this
you just
are in so much pain that the little dumb
micro fears that
uh are the fake problems in our head the
hallucinations tend to be shattered
because you have a real thing and so
i after you were last on rogan and i
listened
um and was
like just blown away by your
grace and um
uh
insight and being just also just
being hilarious and saying the shit that
everyone's thinking but no one will say
which i thought that was my thing and i
was like this bitch and um
so
i was
you know gonna go to sagas memorial and
i just for whatever reason was like
i was like kept planning on asking you
to hang out and i reached out to you and
was just like wanted to be your friend
and i was just like
i feel like
she's gonna be my we're gonna go to
saga's funeral together
yeah that it was i felt so bad because
you'd reach out to me on instagram but i
don't run my instagram i i i'm on it a
little bit more now that i
just have um like traveling sites and
cooking sites i'm like this is magical
place if i like mute everything and it's
just travel and
and cooking but then my
friend who runs it was like oh whitney
would show to you and i was like when
she's like six weeks you know i'm like
you have one job
i had so much more respect for you that
you didn't respond i was like you know
what good for her
she was as cool as i thought she was tim
invited me to your faux thanksgiving
and then you had like a faux
thanksgiving a couple years ago and then
he was like i would have loved you for
you to come well then he was like i was
like i'm running late i may like cry if
i talk about this
i'm so emotional um
he was like i'm running late and he's
like oh she's not having it anymore and
then um they like posted all the videos
and i was like what the fuck and
someone's like oh whitney just hates you
i bet she like told you not to come and
i was like oh maybe so i just assumed
you like hated me so when i saw that dm
i was like oh i thought she hated me
yeah that would never i was like oh
because he was like oh we're
she's not having it anymore because of
kovac but he came yeah i know and then
posted videos of it
it was so weird like the establishment
trying to keep us apart
i don't know
so this establishment being damned
[Laughter]
i don't know i mean maybe i don't know
why he was like oh she's not having it
anymore because of um
like covet or something but then there
were like all these videos on instagram
like did he think that i wouldn't see
that there were like
so what got to you i was like this is
like high school i hate this shit
because here's what i'll say there were
people there that i actually don't like
so even if i didn't like you he would
have been invited
but that is so wild
and such a i do like to on these
podcasts like what we did with olivia
munn and miranda cosgrove women that
i've had like complicated imaginary
pasts with
because i projected onto them like when
olivia came on i was like i used to be
jealous of you and i think i still am
and like you know just like
like
that is so wild because i
do
have like some bullshit projection about
you but has nothing to do with that day
and that was also at the peak of my
really bad edible addiction so
if i may i
wouldn't have i didn't know
oh no i mean i was commenting so none of
that was
but it was
that's so wild because it must have been
like a series of misunderstandings i'm
sure tim wasn't lying yeah but like you
know cause tim will
like he came and he left really i think
he just left really fast remember
remember oh you weren't here so he just
came and like
i think everyone was a little bit like
by the time you got tested and people
were masked and it was like weird and it
was just he him he came and left and
then jim jeffries came and left really
fast and i of course was like why are
they leaving where are they staying like
i was having a mental breakdown because
i felt rejected that's so wild and then
you felt rejected i was just like oh
this is just like why i don't engage
which makes me want to blow my brains
out because my whole deal is i always do
orphans thanksgiving and it's all the
people that don't have places to go not
that you didn't but the idea is everyone
that like either can't don't have a
family to go to and it's all like the
broken toy weirdos and you would have
been and then i saw your message and i
was like maybe i just had it wrong or
somebody like told me the wrong thing
you know they're
do you know don't say the name but do
you know the person that said they
thought i didn't like you i can't even
remember who it was
i was i was talking about it with like
it was it was a woman but i don't
remember who it was
that's i not to judge that woman but
there's no way that person i have never
spoken to anyone about you yeah i've had
thoughts about you in my head
being scared of you and intimidated by
you why and because you
are
so
wildly fearless in a field that is
supposed to be fearless people but
actually most comedians right now are
driven by fear and you just fucking say
it like you're doing what richard pryor
and george carlin did what a lot of
fearless comedians think they're doing
you're actually doing and you call shit
as you see it and as someone who's like
i probably made some mistakes in the
past like she she's probably the first
to call me out of my shit
and she you can't manipulate her or
cajole her or you know like so that's a
scary thing i never really it's funny
like i and i have i have internalized
misogyny from just like competition
fucked up shit with women just in comedy
because of our scarcity complex anyway i
never really i just always it's i was
thinking about you today when i was
coming over because
i was thinking about money shot the
first time i ever saw you was it was
like an experimental year of sobriety
and someone was like have you seen this
girl whitney and i was like oh my god i
loved her and then i just i just always
kind of
looked up to you and i thought your
comedy was so smart like in a in a in a
field where i don't think most like
i think i hate the like women aren't
funny but most women
don't make me laugh and i'm sure most
men don't either you know it's like it's
you know funny no most men don't either
but i do think that men talk more about
things
that are interesting to me generally
because sometimes they'll be more like
topical and and sure and political and
um and you have that kind of smart
incisive humor and so i always just
looked up to you and then i was like
everybody was hating on you when you
sold all those shows and i was like dude
this is like the fucking dream like it's
like winning the lottery selling one
show in this town let alone too we
should all be like cheering for this
shit and people that didn't like me
because i worked too hard everyone's
like she's so ambitious she works so
hard and it's like well this is what
happens while you guys are sitting
around smoking weed and playing video
games like what do you guys do all day
like yeah but i never really
knew you like there was a there were so
much like false
preconceptions i think yeah it's someone
that is used to
just feeling hated by everyone all the
time and i understand that i walked into
a situation where i just like you know i
know that when someone else gets really
successful or has something that i want
or something i think i want or my ego
wants they're just holding up a mirror
to my insecurities and self-loathing so
i just became a mirror
of
what a lot of people didn't have and did
want but my whole thing was you guys if
i can get this and i'm not funny
then you definitely should be able to
get this you just have to fucking write
something and then shoot it and no i
couldn't get cast because i was too loud
i was too tall i was too shrill i always
do this
and then i was like no one's writing for
me so i just had to write for myself
like i don't want to have to write these
shows i wish i could just get cast in
someone else's or that someone will give
me a deal and then write for me which is
what happens to a lot of people but no
one
thought women were funny at the time and
then i did the roasts and you know
whatever but um but i just want to get
back to this because you know
to like hurt someone's feelings by
accident like that's such a wild
but it's so common now this happens
because you're doing because you're
doing the recon of of
i am i do have a resentment towards the
person that said i didn't like you
because i am a lot of things but
not
fucking
down with female comedians is not one of
them yeah and even the ones that are
mean to me and that have been mean to me
and continue to be mean to me i'm always
like i am on that person's side i have
compassion they're sick and suffering we
forgive others not because they deserve
forgiveness but because we deserve peace
and hurt people hurt people and there's
a scarcity like i defend the people that
are shitty to me so even if i didn't
like you
which would have been my problem i it
would have been like oh no she
is recreating my childhood circumstances
my inner child is scared of her she's
intimidating she's fearless like but if
i just meet her i know
if i had a problem with you i'd want to
meet you because i didn't
i wouldn't know i know it's a mirage
but i think that happens so much with um
social media now people are like
projecting
their own because i was like the new
girl i moved every year and a half yeah
so i i'm aware that i have like a
complex you're never gonna click yeah
i'm aware of the fact that i'm like oh
i'm being left out again that's why i
get so emotional
and pregnancy it's so and then i know
you were talking to about uh this with
catherine madigan on the podcast and um
about birth order you're the oldest
oldest okay interesting so you're the
hero no roll
i mean i was until i totally fucked up
and like
um
fell apart and was in rehab
which is common for the oldest a lot
because they were so coddled and they
were the one that got the most attention
and then i think it was just so much
pressure and then
shit just went sideways like i got raped
and drugged and ended up in rehab a year
later and then it was kind of liberating
like it was the first time i really felt
liberated
after
and then i would say even
even the moment where i was like oh i
can self-censor and maybe try and get a
job in hollywood or i can just be
honest and still continue to be poor
yeah
it was another moment where i was like
well i'd rather be poor and free
and i think with and we'll come back to
that in a second like for me
my because i i was insecure about you
because
as someone that i'm not big on having
imposter syndrome but my thing is like
if i'm a phony this bitch will know
i don't think i'm one but i also am the
first to say like addiction and
codependence is in insecurity it's the
disease that tells you you don't have a
disease and you could be you know uh
repeating patterns that you were uh
imprinted with epigenetic imprinting
ancestral patterns you know seeing what
whatever like i if i'm delusional
she will know i don't think i am i might
i'm probably delusional but i don't know
if i can take the risk because this this
person
will see me and cause it like she sees
it and i have no ability to manipulate
her
or
um
beguile her and that's scary because
that's like you would be judgmental
there's very few people that i'm like
that that person is so real that if i'm
a fake i'll have to face it i think we
get accused of like very similar things
though
you know i think both of us get accused
of being opportunistic or just like
walking the fence or being like whatever
going whichever way the wind blows and
instead of realizing that
well in my case i can speak for myself
it's like mostly just being confused and
why do i have so many death and rape
threats like
what if i yeah
i mean that's really interesting because
i always think i get accused of having
like the hottest take or taking the
wrong take yeah it could be the same
thing oh like the other sides will
accuse us of being yeah
like my husband always jokes that my
next t-shirt needs to be captain of the
fence writing team because he's like you
just
you and people on both sides will call
me out for this and i'm like might be
fair criticism maybe that's it's you
know it's inherently
just a self-righteous indignation
addiction because everyone's fence is
different so that's you that your
offense when you say you're riding the
fence i'm like well that's your fence
yeah you know what i'm saying based on
your algorithm and your conditioning and
what you think you know what i'm saying
so it's like your definition of
conservative is very different than my
definition of conservative so until
we've agreed on the same definition of
where the feds is you can't accuse me of
writing it because i think i remember
one time you were getting attacked for
something and i was and it was
boob picture and i posted one in
solidarity under your feet
i don't i had to go offline that was
when a nude well this is this this is
the deal with me is that yes when i get
extorted and a hacker
tried to extort me for a nude
and then i posted it
uh to say so that he couldn't possibly
it's gonna be in my new hour like the
whole story about it everyone's like she
did that on purpose to get press for her
special i'm like don't you think i would
have picked a better fucking photo i'm
in a bathtub my my i'm bent over so my
tits are all like like traffic cone tits
like they're pointy and like not it's
not even like a good
name so bad for you though i was like
that's why i posted started posting
nudes online that was just so people
couldn't do that
i was like from before i was not
anything i just started like if someone
wants to if someone's like
if a tabloid is gonna pay money for a 39
year old's titties this is kind of
progress this is awesome and like and my
whole thing was yeah i was like
you know uh
i had my nudes leaked i was actually way
more embarrassed about all like the
inspirational quotes i had screen
grabbed i was like you guys could have
my titties but please don't tell anyone
about those marilyn monroe quotes like
the oscar wilde affirmation please don't
tell anyone about the oh show quotes
like in my like
recently deleted file but but so that's
why because so i missed all that because
i like went offline like i remember bert
posted a photo of nutsac or something
and then i kind of like had to go
offline because i was getting accused of
like
like pretending i was getting extorted
like i remember even schultz texted me
was like dude that was really smart and
i was like what yeah and i was like
andrew like thank you for thinking i am
that much of a like
calculating psychopath um but it's so
wild to me that we've seen so many nudes
get leaked and women be so embarrassed
and humiliated publicly in this way
constantly incessantly yet
the odds of me faking it are higher yeah
the odds of a woman like are like
orchestrating a fake nude leak like
the data is like what are the chances
that that would be the case but because
i'm
i mean i'm the most apologetic person on
the planet but i'm outspoken i'm not
apologetic i'm loud or i'm shrill i
deserve it there's no way what you're
saying is like there's no way someone
would actually think there was a point
in extorting you you piece of shit like
i was just sort of like
um my tits are fake guys they're great
like they're you don't like you don't
have to throw me a bone you can
you can it's a
why do you gain so much from this not
being true yeah why do you need the
narrative whitney calculated this like
it's bad enough for me i'm suffering
aren't you happy like i'm i've been hurt
publicly like like
like does your like sadistic tendency
know no limit i'm already miserable and
humiliated i hate myself like what else
do you need they're like
she's down so we're gonna kick her yeah
yeah which is like that's the only way i
can come so keep like
all this is the thing that i think a lot
of people don't change like all the
adversity and the dragging and the
canceling with me and the attacking me
it's just like i grew up an alcoholic
home bitch like this is where i thrive
i'm addicted to adrenaline i'm addicted
to this shit like this is
you know uh
you're not hurting me
you're choking me during sex i love it
yeah and i'm at this point that i think
you're clearly you maybe were at a long
time ago after that trauma happened
where i'm like
you either
whether you like me or not has literally
nothing to do with me
and i know i'm a rorschach test i know
i'm polarizing and like if i
i probably would not have liked me
before i got my egr ego eager same uh
ego under control because i
anybody that
you know because i was the youngest in
an alcoholic home and i was also a call
we called a surprise which means
accident
and i think children emily and i kind of
had this like epiphany this past weekend
and
north carolina like
you know many of the youngest children
were not planned yeah and
that doesn't mean they weren't loved you
know but there you kind of know it's
like i was born 14 months after my
sister and you and
you sort of know you're on borrowed time
you know you're kind of walking on
eggshells you're not allowed to you have
to be needless want less like you should
be just happy to be here
but you're barely you're on thin ice
yeah just be having been born you're
lucky you didn't get a border bitch we
just lived in a state where we couldn't
get it done you know or are there
already so many it was like what's one
we're too poor to have a big enough
staircase to throw your mom down like we
just so i was always like you have to be
useful and you have to walk on eggshells
around narcissists you can't um uh have
any emotional needs and everyone was so
exhausted in that capacity and
overwhelmed that if you're like when's
dinner ready it's like well why don't
you just get a new mother
like the littlest needs and i was the
kid that like my mom would drive to work
and then realize i was in the car and i
was like fuck like it was just like i
was always forgotten about i had to walk
home from school like i was just the kid
that had to you know raise myself and
just be
like
make myself useful
and why am i talking about this uh
being
i don't remember
the birth orders the birth order thing
yeah of just sort of like carrying the
shame for existing at all and like oh
this was it minimizing myself making
myself as small as possible needless
wantless i'm just gonna you know which
is was you know ended up being the you
know type of para alcoholism that i um
uh inherited which is you know we say in
order for alcoholism to be present
alcohol doesn't always have to be
present like you can see it in in my
case there was a lot of alcohol but it
can be in you know perfectionism
obsessive cleaning organizing holidays
you know just sort of like the the
inherited alcoholism and codependence of
perfectionism and families and and just
the sick shit that our parents didn't
realize was so harmful of like you're
not leaving the table until you finish
everything on your plate and drink that
whole glass of milk
you know remember that remember the like
either the forced eating
or i remember
we would i never thought that was i mean
until this moment it never occurred to
me that that's weird it's so toxic
it's so we used to just put like peas
around the outside of our plate so you'd
pick up the plate there would just be
like food that we had shoved under the
or like throw it on the ground yes you
would just like put it in your it just
the you have to fit because we didn't
have a lot of it was you have to finish
everything on your plate yeah i mean we
were always racing i eat fast because
there were five of us so we were always
racing to finish so that we could get
seconds i still eat in the car alone
like i when i get food i eat it so fast
we would scarcity no there were fish
sticks and the second they went down
you'd grab them and lick them you licked
as many as you could so how many kids
are in your family not it was just me i
had an older sister a half brother okay
you know but then i lived with my aunts
and uncles for a while in a different
place so i was just like moved around a
lot to different family members so i was
like the weirdo that was in high school
who like lived with her aunt okay you
know what i mean like i was the weirdo
that like there's always a problem there
there's always like shit
it's like i was like the weirdo that
like in virginia i lived with my aunt
and they didn't have kids they weren't
parents so they were like they were like
women in their 40s like like horse
ladies that didn't have kids and their
whole thing was because i showed up with
a nose ring and i've been doing like
drugs on the streets and had like my
head half shaved and shed and we were
like you know ran away from home and
then we're like going to raves and doing
drugs at like
you know 11 12 whatever so by the time i
got there it was like the scared
straight program where they like ripped
the nose right out of my ear and decided
everything needed to be about building
character
so my aunt would drive me to school with
her seven dogs in the back which is like
when you're
in high school when you're like in
eighth or ninth grade you're like can
you drop me off like four blocks away
and then you wanna walk because you
don't want everyone seeing your shitty
car it was like a pickup truck and there
were dogs in the back and she'd stop and
they'd all get out and run
in the schoolyard
and like she'd be yelling like boomer
nugget and all the dogs were running
everywhere and it was just like so
embarrassing
how old were you when you came here to
l.a
64.
i'm 89 years old this baby blood thing
works
i was 20. but i came
when i was 18 i came out and i did the
ucla like summer theater program and i
interned at entertainment at a uh show
called wild on e i pixelated nipples in
post and then i interned at a production
called radar pictures like i used to um
like just cold email people and ask if i
could like intern and stuff so i came
out and i did that and then uh i came
out like a summer because i just knew i
was like i knew that i was gonna and
then when i came out i had auditioned in
new york
for to be like an mtv vj because i would
like send in real world audition tapes
i got on the real world it's like
luckily it never went wait what yeah
wait a minute
no but it never went it just never
wait you shot i want to hear this whole
story so i'm taking these to throw it oh
yeah she has a gun that she shoots me
with when i interrupt i'm talking um
no it was when i was like 22 years old i
had lived out here i moved out here
right right after rehab
and
then i
there was an audition in ithaca new york
my sister and i were living together can
i just say something out loud just to
let's see if it would have been funny
was i gonna say is that who raped you
was it puck
okay the fact that you laugh means we're
gonna be just fine
um
i no we went and drove to ithaca from
rhode island and it was no it was like
dark real world ithaca no that was where
the first audition was okay and people
used to say they're like you were
created in a lab for reality television
and this was i i it's so funny i've been
going through all my old shit in my
garage and like getting organized i go
through it every time i watch dumpster
fire i'm like
i'm obsessed with that set
and so we
my sister was like you have to audition
and we had to go
and like i had to fill out this whole
packet which i'm so mad i didn't fucking
photo mad so mad and then
um but it was like tell us the story of
how you lost your virginity or something
and my story was like to manager when i
was 17 my manager at a restaurant who
was like way older than me at the time
restaurant it was in minnesota and
we so i just had like all these stories
that they just worked for them they're
like this one's fucked up we can tell
and
they ended up um
then we made this amazing we had been
filming everything and this is another
thing that is heartbreaking to me we
made this video
like
parodying the real world my sister and i
because they're like you still have to
do an audition tape even though you made
it to like the next round and it was me
being like i'm really good with kids and
then we cut to me playing with like my
nephew
but i had him like running over elmo
like it was dark and it was like the
opposite of whatever i was saying i'm
like i'm a great sister and it was
always in these weird backgrounds and we
didn't have an editing machine so we
literally videotaped the tv also what's
an editing machine
whatever those things are that you edit
with
we didn't have like
we literally just took the camcorder and
videotaped the tapes over it
next to like the scene that we wanted so
it was like just completely ghetto-ly
put together
janky tape but it was freaking hilarious
and
one day my sister and i were watching it
laughing after long afterwards and her
son like somehow hit the freaking
um
remote he was like crawling around and
wiped the whole thing
and then which by the way like
never happened isn't a feature but he
figured it out like no one would have
known how to do that
and it never happens like whenever you
wanted to record over something you
couldn't it was it was like
heartbreaking and so we went to ithaca i
filled out this whole thing i got i had
just left la and i really just wanted a
trip to come back to la and they're like
we'll fly you i tell you it's sweet i'll
spend a week with my pussy
and i sat in this like crazy room and
they interviewed me and they remember if
it was danny via casting because we can
probably get these two they have all
this stuff and something we asked
someone my cousin met someone who was in
archives and they looked for us and
they're like because what happened was
then
um
they it was supposed to be real world
vegas which i found out like was it over
email was there stuff over email could
you find
no can we log into your
that aol.com um
and we ended up like i came out here
that week was nuts for a lot of
different reasons but it was so fun were
you sober at this time
[Laughter]
by the way uh there's a strong chance
that's not how the tape got deleted but
okay it's not
because he was crawling around and
we ended up um
like then they were like hey we like you
so much but we want you to leave be the
lead on this other show that's on an
island
it was some show so they moved me to
another show and then it's on epstein
island is that cool
it might have been
but so then they're like you had i had
signed up for a certain time and i was
like when can i get out of this because
at this point i was like this is a bad
idea i didn't think it would go this far
i don't know why you're like this feels
like an intervention
an
island did i have cocaine where is this
it just felt like something at that
point i was like how do i get out of
this and
they were laughing at me because the
producers would call and they're like uh
hey we're just checking in on you are
you still around and they're like people
call us every day to see if they're on
this show and i'm like i want out like
the minute that my like you know the
option basically
yeah runs out
and then the option did run out i think
the show did end up going but i was like
take me out of the mess remember what um
it was like i like what year was
paradise it was 2 000
whoa
two or three that's weird because i did
punk 2004
real world road rules challenge the
island
i don't know what it was but i'm glad i
never did made in staten island i'm like
temptation island
thank god
maybe
maybe where they go like see if you're
gonna cheat on your spouse or something
no it was some it was like something in
paradise or something i don't even know
if the show ever got made honestly
nothing on mtv was in paradise let's be
honest let's just take it down a notch
so yeah that was the first time i got
onto a reality show then there was miami
inc which is the second time i didn't
know you're on this i wasn't because it
fell apart at the last minute and like
some fucking crazy
so i fly down to miami wait isn't that
for tattoo artists yeah i was gonna get
my logo attached this was in 2006. i
started my company i was driving around
i'm like i'm taking myself on tour like
a band except i'm a one-woman brand and
i thought this was like pre-kardashians
i just saw the writing on the wall i'm
like we're all going to be our own
brands i'm going to take this shit the
early content creators you guys got that
we i didn't understand that i was just
like we're going to do this and i was
like i want all these rapists to hire me
and give me two percent of the money i'm
bringing in and then i was in miami
and there was a like open call for miami
inc and i said i filled it out went
driving around the country with my my
ban my brand that i ended up going
bankrupt i know you're shocked um
and still the brand but that was a
disaster
and drove around for like six months and
then when i came back found out that i
got on miami inc
they approved my design i was gonna get
my logo tattooed like on my butt because
i thought it was funny
again thank god i mean like that's
saying
that
[Laughter]
i was like i've gotta get on miami when
we were in miami i'm like i see one more
fucking sunrise i'm gonna die like
okay the worst place to be on a bender
is miami the worst it's the it is so
bright it is so humid and this was like
two this is
down there selling i was probably
editing girls gone wild while you were
doing this down there selling daddy
would be proud shirts
that were in the girls gone wild font
like on the beach that was my t-shirt i
was trying to sell up and down i was
doing wild on your girls gone wild i
remember that
and this was the height of it and spring
break and like
the date rape drug and
it was just like the
2005 i think it was just like a weird
those early odds were nuts i know i'm
not allowed to make this joke because
i'm not making it but kt tatara used to
do a joke where he went um
he went uh
this this girl the other day accused me
of date rape like
it wasn't a date
this is always when i hear that amazing
thing of that joke dark dark dark
so we went but also there's there's i've
had fam sorry i've had family members
that are friends and stuff that have
relapsed in florida there's methadone
clinics i mean you can go get methadone
you can go get you know because the
problem is so bad you can go like get
oxycontin really just i stopped doing
all the like heroin after age of 1920
when i got out of rehab but i was
definitely still like on the blow train
did you have the experience in rehab you
know i hear a lot of people they go in
for one thing and then they go to go to
rehab and they hear people talking about
other drugs and they're like when they
get out they're like well i've never
done zany bars but i heard that i tried
pretty much everything i i feel that way
more now in sobriety because the kids
are doing all this weird stuff but i'll
finish my dumb miami story so
i went flew down to miami and got to fly
myself down which is embarrassing to
admit but i did that is the darkest
thing you've said this entire interview
[Laughter]
i don't think i've ever publicly
admitted to anything so shameful
i can't
and i flew myself down and stayed with
some people that i i don't even think
they put me up because they were trying
to cast locally and you probably said
i'm local i probably lied yeah
and they had approved the design and
everything and it was the first day back
back to production since
um
like they had been on hiatus or whatever
and it was their first day back so
everybody was like crabby
and the guys were kind of dickish and
they were giving me shit and then the
guy who was supposed to do my design was
like who proved this design like you did
like
they said you did and so we're supposed
we're like going getting ready to film
and he's like i can't do this it's too
many perfect circles i'm like the tattoo
artist
and then the producer felt so bad and
said are you on cocaine and adderall are
you supposed to like the other one came
out and he's like can't you just get
like a butterfly on your ankle or
something i'm like no i'm not gonna get
a fucking butterfly on my ankle i'm not
like not a whore i'm a hug
i'm a
oh well by the way thank god
amen so can we have an edible
arrangement we'll get you anything we'll
put anything you want cause you would
have gotten an aids man if you haven't
gotten it from pedro
or tetanus or something and then i um i
took a walk and i was like they're like
well go think about a producer felt so
bad because they're being so shitty and
then i was like nah this is like god's
rejection rejection rejection is god's
protection i was like no this is just
this i don't think god is in miami
tattoo shops but i know you mean
maybe he was that day
that was the day
i started believing in god it's like if
i was gonna have a butterfly tattoo on
my ankle i'd have it by now yeah what
i'm saying like look at me to go with
the tattoo on my wrist that says breathe
okay i'm building a brand
don't you see what you're dealing with
here like i am a fucking mess yeah i
think i would have had a tramp stamp by
now it's so wild and then and then i was
so it's weird and maybe that i had this
like
darwinian instinct to not
connect with you until i was like ready
because you your program and the way you
have um
i'm being a perfectionist with my words
perfectionism leads to procrastination
which leads to paralysis i'm trying to
not say the word journey i'm just trying
to not say journey um
i'm trying so hard
to not say you've navigated a journey
our path but the the there's no non-lame
way to say it and look i you know i
am the first to admit my uh flaws i have
an entire book of my character defects i
had to get like an extra notebook like
no one's more self-flagellating and
self-critical than i am even though we
call them superpowers
um
uh it is rare that i hear someone talk
about sobriety where i'm like
i i
am humbled and feel
uh i mean i've been in program for 14
years and like it's just it's
it's i just
know a lot and i and i
uh
you know i and i have shame when i say
that because it's also i know nothing in
the second my mingle like it's activated
or i get you know stressed out or
adrenalized it all goes out the fucking
window and i forget basic mantras like
one day at a time or it doesn't matter
or you know i was just like you know um
uh when i get scared or insecure or
hungry angry lonely tired i will
go to my default software of fear driven
being reactive you know um
because my main drugs are like taking an
action um just having to do something
instead of being able to be in the
discomfort
don't just do something sit there right
so and then every year you're in program
you have another second of pause right
it's like we're not responsible for our
first thought but you are responsible
for your first action whatever but so
i'm the first to say that i will relapse
all the time but um
but listening to you
uh your last episode on rogan i remember
going like i think that if we had been
you had known me any sooner i wouldn't
have been ready for you i would have
been scared of you i would have not been
uh
deserving of your time like you would
have been like this girl's kind of full
of shit or something because i was full
of shit for a really long time because i
yeah of course but i think i mean i
might still be again there's a lot i'm
always wondering like how how good i am
lying to myself which is that but the
kind of people that say that are the
ones that are usually constitutionally
honest the ones that are like and that
was probably if i'm probably being full
of shit and i'm probably being
apologetic or manipulating or you know
shape-shifting or cajoling or like
trying to manage it's hard though when
you come from when you have those skills
yeah and you have to put them on the
back my sisters and i talk about this
all the time because we're like we came
from a psychological ninja that's right
like
we're anticipating
stuff that might not be true and trying
to weasel our way around it and
manipulate and i'm like i don't even
know when i'm manipulating sometimes
because i'm just it's such a default
that it and i'm so
shady like that's my one of my
that's been the nicest thing i think
about the past couple of years of
sobriety is like the shadiness is
it's it's definitely like there's no
shadiness between my husband and i
there's always been like i'm just
sketchy always fucking sketchy
i am the sketchiest bitch like i am
like and
and it boils down to for people that are
like how do you know it boils down to
motives right so my sketchiness
is if i may uh worse
uh i've had it harder no but it's with a
a and alan on so you know alan on adult
children of alcoholics
it's like i would go to double winners
meetings a meetings and i would hear
drug addicts cause my drug is control
and my drug is i'm gonna make you need
me i'm going to rescue you and i'm going
to like you know uh you know alana you
know drug addicts are addicted to drugs
alanos are addicted to drug addicts and
the chaos you give me and the adrenaline
and the cortisol and like you know i get
to mother micromanage and martyr myself
and be a hero and like you know and be
perfect because
perfectionism is our ultimate you know
uh dopamine release and if as long as
i'm with a mess i'm perfect yeah in
comparison even though i'm a total piece
of garbage you know so we surround
ourselves with people that are such
messes so in comparison we can feel like
heroes and we get our self-esteem from
being quote unquote useful even though
we're not being useful we're enabling
the person and probably making them
sicker and protecting them from having a
consequence and having so where does the
sketchiness manifest which is really
quick because i remember the first time
i went to a double winners meeting and
i'm hearing alcoholics and addicts to
drugs talk about you know i drove drunk
and i went through i almost hit a school
bus and i climbed over my ex's you know
uh the fence and crawled in her window
and i'm like bitch i do all this sober
like what like i'm just like it just is
like wild to me because a lot of people
are like melanomas are like the whiners
and it's just like bitch we're as
fucking as gnarly as you i do it wide
awake with no regrets
i still think i made the right choice
i still think i'm nailing it like i
think i'm perfect so
but the shadiness i think comes in it's
it's very uh uh insidious
in alanats and people-pleasers because
we're just being nice yeah but the
motive is really i'm gonna make you
think i'm nice and make you need me so
that you won't abandon me and it's our
you know i remember one of the first
meetings that clicked for me when
someone people pleasing is a form of
assholery yeah because what you're
really saying is uh you would never like
me
just for who i am i don't even know who
i am i'm a michelle of a person i lack
an identity entirely because i just
define myself through other people i
remember in my book i wrote about how
every day guy that i dated i was like a
dare i was like a different i was like a
goth girl for one i was like the sports
girl like brad pitt
is that his thing did you ever see that
picture of like how he shape-shifts with
every woman he starts to look like the
woman that is
so funny
it's my favorite there's a meme you have
a lot of brad pitt you talk about him a
lot on your show yeah we we the whole
last episode was undertones of brad pitt
but he's so
funny
there's a whole thing about this where
he like shapeshifts into whatever woman
he's with that is
yeah like one of the paltry i'm thinking
about them now we have to pull that one
we'll pull up your name it is hilarious
that is ridiculous um but uh but then i
uh
uh in terms of like motives i
you know
it's very hard even for an allen on like
for me like gifting is a big thing right
and i
you know definitely like dabbled in
deading as well like you know look these
addictions it's whack-a-mole right you
deal with the eating stuff and then the
spending comes up you do what was the
first one for you
like for when you first went into
program eating oh no no elena i had no
idea i had a problem i thought it was
nailing it i knew i was i had been
treated for anorexia and stuff but i was
just like these people are dumb they
don't get it this is serving me like i
just played everybody i played the
therapist i played all of them like and
then uh i had i was dating only
really like dangerous addicts like i was
like learning spanish to fight with drug
dealers and like going down and getting
drug dealers out of downtown and like
putting myself like incredibly dangerous
situations like
so grateful every day that i didn't get
so many stds um like it just was like
the girl who if would not
say we need to use a condom like just
like
had just
um
addicted to
danger like very dangerous situations
and uh
you know believed it when the guy said
i'll kill myself if you leave like was
like i have just like giving up
opportunities giving up so much my
mental i mean i was getting how old were
you
oh when i first went to program wasn't
until when this was ago this is like
this was my
i mean
17 8 i mean when i was 17 i was doing
like an older man that was like 40 you
know that like was totally gaslighting
me but i like
when people gasp like me i just get high
on the gas i'm like
like i love it like this is like i would
love to enter into this ridiculous
reality where like you have a house in
greece like let's pretend like i
remember i
you know dated a guy who uh
thank god tinder wasn't around after
watching the tinder swindler yeah
uh like i dated a guy that like told me
he was like an heir to like the campbell
soup fortune or something you're lucky
you're alive it wasn't that but i i just
said that because i remember on rogue
and you talked about how you waitressed
at um oh god for all these rich people
and this is the berkshires no it's in
rhode island fascinating yeah newport
fascinating old money yeah i love old
money making fun of new money it always
cracks me up like that's such a weird
just did you drive an old volvo you
think you're better than me yeah it's
just like i love old money shame too
it's like yeah we don't want anyone know
we have money but we're not gonna like
redistribute the wealth or help we're
just gonna
do you watch succession
i did did you like it it was i was like
i know these people yeah i know i know
these people i know families exactly
like this i know
one of the characters reminded me of a
guy that i grew up with i was like the
the roman i'm like i know i know this
kid i know him well like the sick sexual
stuff and just like and just
just
it's not you know i used to have so many
issues with like trust fund babies and
still kind of do but i i've worked so
much on them because i'm like they
didn't ask to be born into this shit
and i'm so judgmental of them because
i'm like oh it was hard to grow up
around that and be like the girl i was
always working for them to help yeah and
also their peers so it was like a weird
okay they could never really have
real friendships because everyone's
inherently using them and they always
and then and even like one of the guys
was like oh i could you know even if
it was like oh or childhood loves and
he's like and i was like but mumsy would
never
mumsy would never have this and he's
like no like
money marries money like he can't think
like do you think there should be i know
there's like capital gains i guess is
kind of the point of this but like
should people be able to
keep past wealth on the way they do do
we have any structures in place
that try to prevent that from happening
i mean i think they're trying in
california i don't know how i wouldn't
want my offspring to have a bunch of
money i think it would be bad for them i
know a lot of people that have made
money and they're having kids now i'm
like nope they have to have summer jobs
yeah
warren buffett does that like we don't
you don't get any of this money you can
still pass money on onto your kids and
teach them good values and make them
like not
you know
have to work and and appreciate money so
i i think it's how you're raised but
ultimately there's just so much
dysfunction yeah and like
it is weird because again it's the same
thing that fame does to you to a certain
extent you're pa like you're taught to
be kind of parent you get kind of
paranoid is this person after me because
i have money are they talking to me
because i have money because of who my
parents are because of what they need
are they approaching me because they
need some that is a hard
position to be in all the time and it
does i think rewire your has to rewire
your brain but also what i'll say is
even if you don't have money you can
also go well maybe they only want to
fuck me maybe they just think i'm high
no
maybe they want to kill me maybe they
want my drugs like there's even if you
don't have money there's always going to
be a way
to be in that state if you don't know
who you are and if you're which that's a
good point i'm not gonna stop with the
the values and motives thing um because
i don't want to forget that but you know
i do
i do think that human beings
fundamentally need to be proud of
something that they've accomplished in
order to have self-esteem you have to do
esteemable actions people wonder why
they're like on instagram they're like
why is my self-esteem so what i hate
myself i follow like the holistic
psychologist or whatever they follow
like it's reading inspirational quotes
it's all that's selfish that's why in
12-step programs part of the magic of
12-step programs whether everything in
the big book or what bill w did or
whether or not he was a creep who the
fuck knows like it is um being of
service yeah and doing a stable action
so you're not a piece of shit if you
feel like a piece of shit what have you
done today
for someone else and being of service so
like that that
if you're just getting money and not
earning stuff i think that you hate
yourself and that's a dangerous person
lightly
i have what
come i'm not sure
well okay so emily and i got laser peels
but why are you in my camera angle
you don't want nothing
why how could it have just come out of
nowhere
but is it char coal you don't want this
you know what actually hit my lipstick
do you know what it out right there let
me see
it's like a makeup smudge like uh
shadows oh it's like you're just
noticing this yes wait no but look it's
skin from our laser peel but also you
know what actually this is
so we're doing black paint
[Laughter]
no do you want to actually know what it
was so i have uh ancestors uh that were
my grandfather i worked in coal mines in
west virginia and i'm redecorating the
studio and i found these little statues
on ebay that are made of west virginia
coal
and it's a cat and it says i love you
with little this was like a big thing in
west virginia these little statues made
a coal and i think that's cool oh my god
oh my god
he's proud of your smudges but also
and now you have and you're like and i
have an iron lung
well i we know that i have clown lung
from the geisha costume i went in when i
was like twice
you know
you're like smudging gold on your face
i feel about you
babies relate to the working class
but also by the way no this is okay
emily and i when we were in um
south carolina we went and got a
laser like cool laser like fries the top
layer of your face and we're like
peeling our skin is just still peeling
off so i think it's also that it's just
it's just cold i think it's
[Applause]
the freaking guilded age and she's just
like smudging hole
[Laughter]
oh god sorry i uh our main sponsor is
sinclair oil guys sorry
purdue sponsors the podcast like the
zoolander
oh taking a break from bridget and
whitney um you'll notice that whitney is
not here because she ran downstairs to
get some catalina crunch we were looking
for it everywhere but since she eats so
much of it she hoarded it in her pantry
uh catalina crunch is cereal that tastes
great and is zero sugar keto friendly
and low carb just like me if you're
trying to eat better catalina crunch
cereal has the crunch you crave without
the empty carbs it's absolutely
delicious most zero sugar food doesn't
taste delicious but catalina crunch
really nailed this zero sugar low carb
keto friendly plus it packs a whopping
11 grams of plant-based protein and nine
grams of fiber per serving see why
catalina crunch cereal is the fastest
growing cereal brand in america
just go to catalinacrunch.com whitney
for 15 off your first order plus free
shipping that's catalinacrunch.com
whitney not sure which flavor to try
let's ask whitney because she loves it
okay i'm obsessed with catalina crunch
everyone's like we don't have the
products from the sponsor i buy it okay
i this is already opened i take it on
the road with me it's always in my
luggage on my packing list it says
catalina crunch
for grace when we pack and unpack when
i'm touring this is maple waffle
the chocolate is actually my favorite
also
this is all i need to say when it comes
to catalina crunch okay megan fox eats
it done the only thing megan fox and i
have in common and they also make snack
mixes that's catalinacrunch.com whitney
for 15 off your first order plus free
shipping look at it i eat it like on
planes just all day
i know we can't eat on camera right it's
the only thing i don't have guilt about
in my life yeah eating catalina crunch
it's the only time i don't hate myself
now the other thing whitney does
constantly on airplanes is play best
fiends dust best fiends is a mobile
puzzle game that anyone can download and
play whether you have a few minutes or a
few hours best fiends is the perfect
puzzle game to unwind with because
you're having so much fun i'm on level
200 which i think is higher than your
level but i'm not sure
um sounds like you're pretty sure
um so emily i there is no shame in being
competitive i think being competitive is
a good trait to have as long as your
heart is in the right place and you're
motivated by
self-betterment and bonding over the
competitive nature
emily is beating me in best fiends but
i'm going to let you have it right
because it's really all i have
you're beating me everywhere else i'm
going to let my best friend
beat me at best fiends just so you can
beat me at something and that's a great
fiend
by the way
because you know i'm gonna do
for you what you did for your sister
your sister's wedding
this makes me the best person on the
planet
do you want to tell everyone i'm just
let you oh can i oh yes said oh emily
put on weight on purpose to be heavier
than her sister at her sister's wedding
you're welcome that is truly
emily
anything you need to know about emily
she ate peanut butter for three weeks
buy the jar buy the jar so that she
would be heavier than her sister at her
sister's wedding so that her sister
just shined
shined uh and that was 15 years ago and
i still haven't lost it
the game features tons of cute
characters that help you solve thousands
of fun puzzles the more you play the
more characters you collect and the more
you win the more challenges you face
ready to give your brain some tlc
download best fiends free today on the
app store or google play that's best
friends without the r stop promoting
bad friends by accident guys i will not
support that podcast how dare we
accidentally give them more press than
they deserve
best friends without the our best fiends
now back to our new best friend bridget
i remember when i was bringing someone
to rehab once and
uh
that the head of the rehab said
uh was like so what what are we dealing
with and i was like it's zany bars it's
it's codeine it's this it's the cough
syrup stuff it's a little bit like just
to plan like what the detox was gonna
look like you know and yeah he goes okay
i don't care about now that matters does
this person have anything to be proud of
and i was like
because the person had just been doing
drugs for you know 10 years couchsurfing
whatever and i was like uh i don't i
don't think so and they're really like
i'll never mind he's like this is gonna
be a problem yeah so i think earning i
think people want to earn their money i
think people want to
have done it themselves you know in this
society and with the way student loans
fucks you and the way that like
you know people are paid and it's hard
to do that but i do think just getting
money is like a really toxic some are
made for people good points
yeah it was you know
someone said and and like make making
money is a very american idea they're
you in most countries the word is earn
money you don't make it only and only in
america can you like counterfeit money
well counterfeit but
make it and they were talking to me
about this um in regards to my patreon
in which i was selling boob shots back
to like being a 40 year old who's
getting obsessed with that by the way
you know milf is the number one search
thing in porn well hey uh you know a new
career would you breastfeed there's a
woman that breastfeeds on only fans and
she makes like a million dollars a year
why do you hate money yeah and you're a
bad feminist i'm booked a girl you know
what i'm saying this is yeah that was so
good yeah by the way emily got i like
literally i shouldn't look i'm never
gonna fire her she's never gonna quit
we're in trench to work great gardens
but if i was gonna fire you i would have
done it by now because she started
getting dms from guys saying if you
send me a video of you
having a wedgie in through your pants
i'll pay you seven thousand dollars and
she said no oh
i mean i understand she called her dad
and said can i do this and he said no
it was a dm just
all you would have had to do is give
yourself a wedgie and jeans no he said
um
but i didn't have to show my face
oh wow okay i know
i know i just couldn't do it was it
still in there
so i blocked him
white women are wild
i don't see any i would i would do that
right if someone asked me to do that
right now i would do it for seven
thousand dollars
someone might ask you to do it right now
let's go let's go i will absolutely do
that you know defuntisse when she was on
was talking about how she used to get
these requests for like you know all
this money for these specific videos
where men were like i want you to wear
you know lingerie and like litter in the
woods
and she would do it and it would be like
20 grand it's like that yes
yeah i wish i i could do that stuff you
wouldn't give yourself a wedgie on no
without your
face in it
why not i don't know why not
thank you but you don't know so you
don't have an argument well
no i don't have an argument this is why
women women you know what it's your
fault that women don't make as much as
men they have the opportunity and you
won't fucking take the jobs because it
doesn't feel right women get paid 72
cents to the dollar no they don't fish
you're getting offered
seven thousand dollars so many
are you in a relationship oh no no
well
a lot of people on do more things
together
okay whatever you say
um uh but yeah i don't know it's just
that i'm not sure how my husband would
feel about the uh seven thousand dollar
wedgie shot either he'd be fine with it
i'm gonna tell you something he'd
pretend he wasn't but even just i mean i
don't know i i
yeah
so it's like a decent proposal a decent
proposal yeah which happened to me
actually when i was in park city i got
offered a lot of money to be with a
couple and i said no
and i was
so broke trying to make money to get
back to la who was the couple it was
just some gizzly
by the way i've watched those
documentaries and i fucking hate them
because i would have been one of
epstein's girls and i know that 100
we both wanted oh my god
i just wasn't blonde no they were gonna
weird
definitely when i was like 20 21 was
around people like that and i was not
i was actually a little too mouthy and
not in the good way i was like he loved
those mouthy white trash checks down in
florida but i was like there's a couple
people in hollywood that are very
powerful men
that i have talked to now that were
definitely like they weren't rapists
they were just kind of like dated too
young and used the fact that they were
producers or agents and cast extras that
he wanted to you know like just like
slow abusing power kind of thing but not
you know rape necessarily just not you
know
and then there was a couple that
are like kind of notorious in hollywood
uh and
i would i would like i've talked to them
recently you know because i was like are
you going to cancel me or whatever and
i'm like i'm like no you never did
anything and they're all like yeah you
weren't
there was no in with you because i was
like i was always like so what do i do
with my money and how do i get in sag
and i was always like
like agents that took me out to dinner
that was secretly a date i truly thought
we were having a meeting and i was like
so here's the one i want to do in my
career like they could they were like
and you wouldn't drink and you like had
to go to stand up afterwards like you
just it was impossible to kind of like
like take advantage of you because you
wouldn't stop talking
you were too ambitious to even like suck
an asian stick to get ahead because
which is strange yeah history and then
we're like no i'm going to do this much
harder i want the hardware yeah i know
it was like and and because that dick is
going to be soft let's be honest after i
get done with it but um uh yeah they
were like and one of them was like yeah
we went out twice and both times we got
in arguments about abortion
and i was like just trying to fuck you
and i was like i'm sorry like what a
nightmare
um but anyway
yeah so they were trying to use me for
sex i was trying to use them no
they suffered me a lot of money i was
waiting tables big shock and
um they said just just for one night and
i said no and i i still was like why did
i say no to that i don't even know why i
said no
it felt like it was crossing some line
for me yeah
like
that
a line that i hadn't really crossed i
guess i mean that's which is
prostitution though like that that's
which is fine um we love them
i was talking to a really smart funny
amazing uh actress about something
recently we were talking about just sort
of like the woke woke to woke woke mcgee
and she's like
am i allowed to not want my daughter to
be a sex worker i know it's interesting
i had a conversation for the podcast
with these two radical feminists
and they're
they want to abolish porn and
prostitution and they think that it's
negative and i was like oh that's so
weird i didn't know feminists believed
that but i guess that is like old school
feminism and they're like yeah this new
school feminism they said look at what
we have we want people to look at what
their our allies are doing not what
they're saying because are these women
who are like yay prostitution yay this
are they do they want their daughters to
be strippers and prostitutes are they
encouraging that of their kids and it
was such a
if she was using it to get to something
else and it was on her terms and a
choice and not whatever like you can go
through that but yeah it's too big of a
it's there's just two it requires too
many nuances it was fascinating i
decided this past weekend to not talk
about something unless i have the
ability to put it in context
um but it won't matter
by the way
and so but in terms i just don't want to
uh uh not close the hatch of the motives
because i feel like we're kind of blue
balling a bit
um not that there's such a thing as
balls or gender um or blue
blue oh no i'm those i'm talking about
democratic testicles the blue balls um
that uh that the motives of like of you
know
when we can trick ourselves and when we
like
when are you full of shit and when are
you not full shit and i think it's about
your motives i can give an example of
something recently where i was like
i'm being the thing i'm judging
and being that shadiness that shows up
like when i was working with my first
sponsor in 2013 when i got sober
and i was like she got me a squirrel for
my keychain because i'm like it's just
squirreliness like it just it's weird
and shady and moving but it's from
surviving to the living it's you were
survivor you had to be a little fucking
yeah conniving i
and i was like wow you become
like growing up under communism does
some weird shit to your brain you know
like you're just kind of it's just you
know how obsessed with russian people i
am okay
there's an ongoing joke that i can i
have like a superpower it's my only
superpower i can smell
russians
and i'm not i've been saying this for
years i'm like i could smell that do you
know that i and i went into a restaurant
and i was like it smells like russians
in here and it wasn't an attack
no it's just it's like a pheromone i
don't know what it is i was like smells
like russians in here and she's like
okay whatever poison everyone in the
restaurant started speaking russian
everyone was rushed she was like what
the fuck i never believed you had this
power until right now she's like holy
shit
he's just full of it i'm like it's gonna
save my life someday someday someone's
gonna be like gonna be like the
americans and i'm gonna be like this
fucking person is russian they're gonna
kill me
like there's no reason for that i mean
tim dillon is a russian bot let's be
honest uh you didn't see that so but no
that's so wild because i'm just obsessed
with the fact that like russia is this
you know alternative real i mean it's
just like the fact that russia exists in
in 2022 is so wild to me i have these
russian movers that i will like pretend
to have stuff to do just so i can have
them come over and ask them questions
because uh uh i i don't know the
statistics on this but um and neither
would he neither would anyone no one's
doing this poll because of vladimir
putin
that he says most of his russian friends
and family he's like most people i know
in russia believe that vladimir putin
has doubles that have gotten plastic
surgery to look like him
and that it's not even him like
everything for the longest time in
russia they've been on some simulation
shit yeah some like jean beaujourd
post-modern simulacra for like years
like the news has never been the news to
them like they know everything is
propaganda like they're it's the fact
that vladimir putin if someone disagrees
with him they just die the next day
there's like no point in even fighting
it yeah and they've just accepted this
sort of bizarro world where they protect
they've like
like it's the truman show where putin is
the leader and
everyone's gonna end up getting killed
by russians because of this conversation
so back to the point of how my
upbringing was like russia
no just the shadiness of like there's
five chicken mcnuggets like i'm gonna
put i'm gonna put the peas under my
plate like
yeah shady and i i think too because
it's that survival instinct i found
myself in our space in the in my new
space which i actually didn't think
there was a grosser space than hollywood
but it is like media
and being yeah like in the in the like
pundit world i was like oh this is it's
all charlotte's fucking grosser than
anything
um and here i am it's people that
couldn't act me couldn't write people
like no this is a failed comedian who's
a pundit now i'm like yeah i mean i have
no evidence to suggest that's not true
also comedians i i i this is why i
disagree comedians are supposed to get
successful
at least public at like 40 45. like
rodney dangerfield ellen ray romano all
these people like this whole thing where
comedians are supposed to get famous at
25 when they have absolutely nothing to
fucking say or nothing to offer the
world like that
as a female comedian this is the perfect
trajectory this is when we get
interesting and we've put in our 10 000
hours i just i i ended up um but i was
there were people in the space roseanne
had three kids yeah when she got her
sitcom yeah that's true and i've been
doing stanford 20 years i mean it's like
that's how the real the real deal
trajectories are journeys journeys we're
supposed to go um there were two there
were like two people in the space and i
found myself
um
being like oh there's such opportunists
i'd be talking to like my husband i'd be
like i these people are so full of shit
and then i'd be nice to them and i'm
like i have to fucking stop this like
this is me being opportunistic and shady
but i'm so i it's like business and
diplomatic but i'm like it's not honest
yeah yeah yeah i'm not being honest we
also don't have to be chronic
oversharers and we don't have to be
honest to the point of self-harm either
because i will sometimes over divulge
and over share which is kind of another
point of manipulating another way of
trying to be the victim in the situation
going like uh you know i'm programmed to
be shady and like right now i'm just
trying to make you like me and i'm now
really well i won't tell them this i
just said to my husband i have to stop
pretending that these people are my
friends when they reach out to me
because they need something you know
it's and i will respond and be
that was it was just an awareness where
i'm like i'm being shady too i'm i'm
being opportunistic and shady just by
trying to be like diplomatic and
maintain these relationships because it
might be better for my career you're one
of the i mean there's just so few people
that that
can
you can or talk the way you talk and
it's just and have this awareness of
like if you point one finger at someone
else you're pointing through it yourself
like all these like sort of platitudes
from program where you're like yes i
mean like my sponsor any time
i would say uh
uh
like this person is like told me they
were coming and they didn't come and
then they've been canceling and then
they're not showing up and she's like
she'll be like
well you've done that
and so you always the first thing is if
you're mad at anyone you go oh i've done
that yeah that's why i'm having this
reaction it's my ego or i'll say to her
this person was yelling at me and then
lost their shit and started screaming
and then screamed at the crew and then
and then she'll go
sounds like they're in a lot of pain
and you're just like fuck you know but
there's no
there's no world in which that person's
actually trying to hurt you they're
hurting themselves and you're just
you know the collateral damage unless
it's a
statistic rapist narcissist whatever but
we're talking about people that are just
their inner child is running the show
and they're recreating their childhood
circumstances and they're just trying to
get the they're hurting themselves
normally and we're
since we're constitutionally i'm the
piece of shit in the center of the
universe everyone is just running around
all day trying to figure out how they're
going to hurt my feelings
because like the insecure narcissist of
it all but this is one that made me come
to mind this is a small one but
like my shadiness will come up in
saying yes to plans that i have no
intention of following up
and i did it for so long because i'm
like my brain's like i don't want to say
no to this person because i'm going to
hurt their feelings because if i say no
they'll kill themselves
if i don't hang out with them they'll
just just jump off what like life's not
worth living anymore you fucking
narcissist it's like when i would like
run around and do things out of
obligation like i used to live just out
of obligation i gotta go to this baby
shower i gotta go to this birthday party
i gotta get this thing and i remember um
my sponsor always said like i just and
then i would over commit myself like
getting car accidents getting tickets
because i'm speeding not eating showing
up for like two seconds
and then leaving and going to three
things at night and being like
like
like what would happen if you didn't go
to that birthday party do you think that
she'd like call it off
do you think everyone's like well
whitney's not here should we just
cancel that go it's just like no one's
gonna notice that you didn't go like
it's fine if you don't show if you're
like someone's bridesmaid show up if you
made a commitment but it's like i
this insecurity of like i can't not go
because i want them to like me but
anyone worth being friends with
doesn't want you to do anything you
don't want to do yeah so if i'm doing it
out of obligation it's just like grow
i'm i'm assuming that they keep score
which is what i do yeah because i'm like
well i went to her birthday party this
year last year and she didn't come to
mine so i'm accusing her of doing the
shady shit i'm doing
you know it's like when we
you know quote unquote help and rescue
people and micromanage and martyr like
what you're really doing when you quote
help adults
you know before you solve a problem
first make sure it's your problem yeah
when we insert ourselves in other
people's shit as adults what we're
really saying it's like well i'm just
trying to help now what you're really
saying is
you're not smart enough to figure this
out yourself and you're just dumb
and you'll ne so i'm just gonna help you
you know what i'm saying like it's just
like it's so arrogant like when you boil
it down to the subtext even though your
narrative is well i'm helping this
person like i genuinely believe i'm
doing something nice you know yeah that
was that whole difference between um
um oh god what is it like
selfishness and
what there's those like two like it's a
subtle difference and one is when you do
do something
because you want you're like giving
something but you want something in
return essentially versus just being
selfish
yeah and
that was always i i really hated like
having to look at that you know for all
the stuff people say about program or
whatever that that like four step
i was worried about the apologies like i
don't think i ever would have done
program had i known about the fourth
step where you're like taking that
inventory yep that and those inventories
are brutal which for everyone the
inventory is did you do the blueprint
for progress that's one that's like aca
uh sex and love addiction it's like it's
kind of just like a real gnarly one
because a lot of times in aaa or naranon
or you know something with substances
it's a lot of like i stole money i
crashed your car you know yeah but for
al and on it's a little shadier it's
like
i expected you to have tools you didn't
have like yeah i basically well for the
apologies really quick sorry i was so
humble sorry i love you too much yeah
it's like that it's like we're the ones
like i'm sorry i just loved you too much
you know i was like you weren't ready to
you know like for someone that was this
giving i'm sorry you couldn't receive i
was giving you too much you know that
bullshit but like
in aaa it's a lot of sort of more cut
and dry like i did these illegal things
and you know it's but some of it some of
it but in al anon there's a lot of like
uh i'm sorry i lied to i you know lied
about having more money than i had like
shit like that it's just like sticky
it's like sticky shit that
it takes a couple
times to do that step like i did my
four-step product to my sponsor like
boom which my favorite thing is in al
anon uh
whenever so it'll be like i did my
fourth step um
i give myself like a b minus because
we're such a perfectionist we have to
like we're the ones like yourself
like my handwriting wasn't good so i had
to start over like i could recopy it um
and uh
i did i turned my four step which is
like like all the sort of taking my
inventory like how do you explain i'm
never good at explaining that so
essentially
the way i did it and have done it a
couple times is
you just make a list of everything that
like every resentment you have yeah so
there's like the resentment inventory
the fear inventory and then we'd do like
a sex and relationship
but ours is called blameless inventory
which is like because al anons are so
already think that they're the re uh
right like so inherently bad i'm already
such a piece of shit that sometimes we
have to put the kid gloves on it's a
blameless inventory this is just like
stuff that you've done that you're not
proud of you're ashamed of but like like
because we already like have so many
notes for ourselves and criticism is
already so hard that it's called
blameless inventory okay yeah so that's
not what it's called at the one i did it
was more just a straight kind of old
school big book version of it where you
write your resignments down and it can
be anything like people places it can be
institutions i had like the one percent
on i love it i love it people that you
resent your it could be my uncle who
abused me or and that's one thing about
aaa that i always tell like 12 step that
i tell young women is in particular that
i'm working with is it's not trauma
informed at all it was written in like
the 1930s right right and so it can be
you know though they'll be like oh
what's because it all leads up to you
take the inventory you write and the way
i was taught you just go down and write
one less than like a column so that
you're not going across and then you
would do
um what happened or my sponsor said what
did you perceive happen
which i loved oh hashtag
speaking of that i was in a 12-step
meeting during all of the like believe
women stuff and i looked at my friend
and i was like do you believe on women
she's like hell no i don't believe any
of these bitches
we don't even believe all women yeah
it's so
so simplistic but also and then
six months later the word women is
cancelled so it's like are we even
allowed to say women
believe women but not but only men oh my
gosh so insane um and so then you do
like the other part that i found really
interesting was the instincts that it
affects so it's like pride ambition
sex money
what instincts is this affecting this
like perceived slight or actual
resentment that you have and then your
defects of character but the most
important column is always like what is
your part and one of the big issues that
people can i just say sorry on aca
there's also
what was my
physical reaction and then what was my
reaction so you do like where did you
feel it in your body and how did that
like what did you did you did you cry
did you isolate did you sleep with
everybody did you sleep with someone did
you cheat like how did you act out in
reaction and then how did the how did it
physically affect your body like your
your chest gets warm or i got nervous or
anxious right
um
we didn't have that column but that
would have been interesting and then um
they they so yeah that the problem that
a lot of people have is that when
something like when i was
drugged and raped at 17.
like my part is
it's it's not that i said i was hot
yeah it's really cute i mean there's
stuff like i shouldn't have been doing
but it's not my fault that i got raped
and
so people will say you take too much
responsibility because there is no real
trauma but it it's i had a great sponsor
who was like it's not
like something that's not your fault
that you had no control over is it's how
is this still playing out in your life
today yeah how is it affecting you
yeah why are you are you like holding on
to shame or holding on or being hyper
promiscuous or what how are you reacting
to this now
so i found it very helpful but you do
start seeing patterns yeah like it's
crazy it's like oh there's that shit
again where i'm manipulating men because
i want them to love me with my sex yeah
and which which is like you know a tool
that you know for me and i was just
talking to a sponsee about this because
you know
there's oh thank you
are you bored of us talking about
program boring boring i'm perfect
um for our listeners um when he's
talking to her dog
okay um
honestly no she's talking to you too
they're like thank you turn off that was
your inner monologue by the way
um
so
we were talking about he's like can we
move on
emily's like i have no trauma
um uh
no there's a hold on
there it well first i wanted really
quick just adult children of alcoholics
this is something i was just gonna read
some of the laundry list just as i um
and i am pivoting because i did lose my
train of thought but i'm going to
remember it about like
it took me a sec because it's so
amorphous it's so like
insidious
the
a lot of this stuff especially with what
you're saying the hyper
promiscuity stuff like that like i feel
like i think about this next generation
of women
and i'm like god it must be even harder
to be able to identify that because
we're in this time that's like free the
nipple fuck everyone sexual liberation
like sleep your way to empowerment which
is fine if that's what you're choosing
but it must be kind of harder because
there's someone that promiscuity was a
big part of how i wounded myself and got
a false sense of self-esteem and control
and power yeah i think right now i would
be very confused i talk about this a lot
how
i feel it's a it's like such a again
requires so much nuance because i don't
want to slut-shame people for be out
there like i
i resist a lot of the double standards
where men can fuck whoever they want and
then
women women can't but on the other hand
i do feel that um
somebody was working with this 19 year
old in a restaurant and she was like she
just slept with a guy and she came into
work and she was like have you ever
regret anyone you slept with i'm like um
all of them
she was like oh my god i was like maybe
one or two i have a regret but up until
i got sober i can't it was and it was
such a weird moment for me where i was
like yeah i don't know how many of those
people i would have slept with had i had
any fucking selfishness yeah yeah yeah
yeah and i thought that i was gonna be
able to like sleep my way to self-esteem
and it's not it's not something it only
made everything worse but i also do look
at this next generation of women a lot
of the ones and i'm granted they're not
having sex i'm sure there's that but
there's also a lot of the ones i'm sure
that i come in contact with they're
probably already a little more confident
because they're coming up to me whatever
but i you know
the way that they're able to stand up
for themselves i'm like dude it took me
15 years of program and like
20 years of equine therapy and pros to
be able to say no
when i like would go into a store and
they'd be like ma'am can i help you with
them something do you want to buy this
and i'd be like okay fine like i can't
say no
like do you want a side of guac sure
i don't like i like the people pleasing
i can't say no
to the smallest things much less you
know because we've been conditioned i'm
doing a tv show
where it's a pretty brutal sexual
assault drama thing and we were talking
today and i was like you know i come
from the generation where a lot of the
sex i had was
uh
to placate and it was like
we were trained to believe
that number one because i went to
catholic school not slamming catholicism
like i'm just saying
are we gonna talk about bad sex we are
not
we can if you want to
yeah
[Laughter]
you mean virgins
know about how i i was i was a very uh
tall kid i looked 15 when i was 10 and i
was in catholic school uniform and that
is a very sexualized uniform and i
didn't know at the time i was getting a
lot of attention from men
unbeknownst that i was you know catholic
school girls walk home from school and
we go to the coffee shop afterwards and
we're playing soccer or whatever and
we're like you know sexualized before we
even really know it because of the
association and all that repressed stuff
and
porn catholic school girls is sexy it's
like a sexy thing unfortunately but um
so i i got farms where uh they were i
mean they are if i really need to like
win a fight if or if i'm like in trouble
with my guy i've got like two little
tennis skirts in the back it's like a
like a hook line and sinker every time
um and uh
and so then uh uh
why am i like i'm like bla i'm so
like determined to make you like me that
i'm like
i'm trying to make this i'm trying to be
like so articulate that i'm getting a
little bit paralyzed but in uh
in the sexual life
you were saying you came up from a
generation there was where men
if men wanted to fuck you you tempted
them
and that it was your fault for because
men are weak
and if you're sexy or hot you're putting
them in a situation where they're
tempted
and men get blue balls and they are
physically in pain if you don't fuck
them like you're hurting them right if
you say no
and i was very much conditioned that the
worst thing that i could ever do to a
man is embarrass him or reject him
so
like you know which is so sexist towards
men they're so pathetic that they can't
you know what i mean control their
desires or have any self-restraint you
know i grew did grow up around a lot of
sex addiction uh which at the time you
don't know that's what's happening
you're just like who were all these
women picking me up from school um and
uh and so i learned like if you
kiss a guy
you know for more than 10 minutes you
have got to fuck him because you have
our the has left the barn
and you have to finish what you started
because you're gonna embarrass this
person and they're gonna literally be in
physical pain so you've already made
your choice you don't get to change your
mind halfway through you know so there
was a lot of sex that i had that was
just like
is this isn't rape but it's like i'm
just i'd rather just get this i'd rather
just like i don't really care enough
you're like having sex to avoid the rape
yeah
i'm just like i'd rather like i have an
orgasm anyway this isn't it's just like
an awkward
like i'd rather have bad sex with you
and have to identify with those because
i come from a lot of people maybe it was
just the kind of guys that i attracted
or the kind of guys i was attracted to
where it was like when you said no
it was like okay now let's start
negotiating yeah you know what i mean it
wasn't like it's like i don't want to do
and i didn't at the time i never learned
responsible communication until i was in
allen on you know
direct communication i was always know
as a no it's a complete sentence no i
was like no i don't want no thing no i
don't think so like i was relying on
them to make the right choice always and
i was going to be vague in my body
language and what i was saying and how i
was saying is was not going to be
congress it was just on you to just make
the right decision the young girls today
are so impressive i remember again
working at that same restaurant and i
was 35 and there was a young girl and
she was like standing on him on a ladder
trying to get something down and we had
a creepy manager which i had been used
to my whole 20 years in the restaurant
industry and he had his hand on her leg
and i i
was like
and she's like don't touch me
she just like straight up called it out
and i was so impressed i was like
wow the amount of time that i've let men
like touch my boob touch my butt like
let that shit slide just because i'm
like i'm not fighting this fight i'd be
fighting all the time in the restaurant
if you were if you were open to
like a sane
exchange
you wouldn't have done that in the first
place like there's no point in arguing
with someone that already thought that
was a good idea my brain is like there's
nothing i'm not
if you think it's okay to do that
what's the point of even drawing a
boundary you're just gonna go like oh
like it just is like gonna beget more
abuse for me one of the girls that that
i was writing a lot about this and
talking about this and i'm like i don't
know you like have to
pick your battles and whatever and some
it's i kept getting hearing from young
girls like just because you old birds
put up with this shit doesn't mean we
need to
and that's fair
that's definitely fair it was like i
came from a place the same as you where
i was like uh
you just it was like you know post
sexual revolution and post
like second wave going into third wave
feminism but it was still very like and
i'm also the same person young women and
they have clear consent and boundaries
and i didn't hear any of that shit
growing up which is also i'm also the
same person that is like
you know
you can say that i'm like you know
intern a lot like hate myself or a bad
feminist or whatever like but i'm almost
the same person that does hang out a lot
of male comics and sometimes they pull
out their dick and i think it's funny
you know what i mean or like it's like
i'm also the first person
to think some really inappropriate shit
is funny you know and that is what today
with kids like my sister is so adamant
about like you don't have to give nana a
hug when you see her yeah that's
something interesting too you don't have
to kiss her goodbye like you know what i
mean like there was a lot of that give
auntie a kiss give up come sit on my lap
go give your grandfather a hug and it's
like you don't have to do that yeah like
santa my sister's like i'm not going to
make my kids sit on an old man's lap
like every other day of the year that
would be the worst idea yeah yeah she's
my king she's screaming and crying and
i'm like no no sit on this old you know
what i mean everyone was crying in the
line for santa yeah
i don't want to say that
we would always sit on santa's lap in
the fucking tyson's corner mall and you
would i knew the smell of whiskey
i knew it by then okay like the kids
that came from alcoholic homes knew that
santa had a fucking flask you know what
i'm saying and like his beard it was
that and clowns i was always like i
remember the first time i
like clowns you the fact that our
parents let
i mean
street drunks into our house there was
no one that was
went door to door as a clown no offense
clown community
i'm coming hard okay if you were an
adult man how did you even find clowns
back then like the phone book like how
did clowns get contacted like like like
like push pins on cork boards in the
park
pretty
we invited men into our homes that were
like wearing makeup during the day
to like make balloons for children and
like we you look back down you're like
those were just fucking drunks because
those were jobs without background
checks that didn't have w they took cash
like you just paid them in like snack
wells you never saw that real fake news
and then i remember the first the first
like perfect cover i remember the first
time i got like a drink in a bar i like
got like an omerto sour i was like why
does it smell like clowns like you know
you know you know if you're like that
that's a clown
and then
oh dude i remember also the first time i
did a tv show
in hollywood it was in the first but i
did some pilot and i remember wearing
like those big clown shoes you can walk
fine in them
you can walk fine they would be like
they were wasted like it was just like i
just none of that shit adds up when you
look back these were criminals in
disguise totally
and why did you have to wear a face
paint in order to make little balloon
animals like you don't have to cover
your face no it's funny and and no one
liked the clown no one but our parents
just invited also like i was thinking
about this the other day babysitters
dude
the qualifications you needed to meet
to be a babysitter
was does she live in the neighborhood
yes
and it's still true though it's like is
she a neighbor's teenage daughter yeah
that's still true i think in most like a
lot of small towns it was the big
process suburban america i had so many
babysitters like do crazy weird shit
even in l.a when i was babe like a
couple years ago when i was babysitting
and i had someone text me like hey i got
your number from a friend who you mean
being my assistant
someone was like oh i i got your number
from a friend who i've never worked with
like she just had my number on reserve
it was like will you come babysit my 15
month old and she sent me a picture of
him and was like comment tomorrow at
three and i got there and i was like i
should take this kid just to teach her a
lesson oh god but you were referred by
someone but i hadn't worked for that
person do you know what i'm saying like
that's crazy you're blonde and white
those blonde white girls never do
anything sketchy hashtag liz i'm a
phenomenal babysitter so yeah she lucked
out but i was like you need to be more
careful yeah that is that is i mean the
number of like random i had a russian
babysitter for a long time who always
had like mad german babysitter men in
the house and would like take he would
take stuff out of the like i remember
seeing stuff and just being like she
used to tell us if we ate mustard our
eyes would be sealed shut forever mine
said that mustard is the only condiment
that doesn't have
calories
and i shouldn't eat ketchup i should
only eat mustard i was being like fat
shamed by these like and she would
squeeze my um arms and say like no you
can't have more of this and that and
then she would also pick lice bugs out
of my head and like throw them in my
face to like teach me not to use hair
brushes at other people's houses i did
always have lice until i was like 14.
i was all i always had lice because
remember when you would have to do the
rid and the next to get the comb
we would never wash you have to wash the
sheets and like all your everything yeah
yeah and then i also
would steal from when i would go to like
sleepovers if i could make it through
the night which i normally couldn't i
would get like freaked out and scared
and whatever and that uh which is when
like we found out that i had some must
have had some sexual abuse in the basket
because at like 2 a.m i'd be like
where's your dad like where's your guys
are there any men in the house and i
would like my mom enough like pick me up
and take me home i was the kid that
would like freak out at the sleepover
and uh uh the moms are like let's get
this one out of here but i can't get
this slice
[Laughter]
oh my misophonia i wanna i'm i'm having
murderous tendencies guys it's vitamins
shake it around
good times it's rituals essential for
women 18 plus multivitamin it was
formulated by extensive and exhaustive
research how do you not want to hear it
why don't you open the gift i gave you
oh i'm sorry i gave emily a present i'm
scared and she has not opened it a thank
you gift these are beautiful look i just
was so much better than the last pearl
necklace i got
in college
gorgeous why did you get this for me but
why are you
i feel like you're acting are you being
fake no i love you do you really like it
i really like it i'm are you firing me
no
is this like are you quitting is this a
good vibe
isn't that pretty look how gorgeous it
is i got emily
yeah i mean as if we need to fuel the
fire on us being lesbians any more than
we already are when he gave emily a
pearl necklace
no i think i just it it i wanted to
thank you because you've been um really
showing up for me as a friend lately and
i knew yeah you would i know you would
never buy for yourself because i know
you won't take care of yourself and and
this but are people going to think this
was staged
i do i'm i'm flat this is so generous i
can't believe you got this for me i'm
i'm worried you can't is there something
happening
no i'm just saying i'm not dying i just
i'm embarrassed about the way you dress
there it is this is when you start
dating a new guy and you start giving
him clothes and it's just a way to just
funny because you would make fun of me
for wearing pearls i feel like see this
is what i would but i know that's who
you are but it's also i think as women
like we it's just as anyone anyone it's
not about a woman thing but like we
don't take care of ourselves and for me
it's like if i had 200 in my bank
account i would buy someone else
something instead of take self-care
so
like i did i think three years ago
before ritual was even a sponsor i was
gifting ritual subscriptions to friends
of mine because i'm like i know you
would not do this for yourself right and
you put everybody else first but in
order like you put your oxygen mask on
for first before you put it on the
person next to you if you take care of
yourself first you can take care of
everybody else yeah like you do not
give away unless your
your cup is
runneth over and you you can't give what
you don't have right so
i know you would never buy that pearl
necklace for yourself so i got it for
you is it a blood pearl maybe i don't
know were the oysters raped i i don't
know i'm sure there's hopefully that
means they're fancier i'm sure that's
problematic in some way yeah but so
rituals essential for women 18 plus
vitamins formulated by exhaustive
research to help
[Applause]
fill nutrient gaps in the diet of women
ages 18 plus it's formulated with
nutrients to help support the brain
health bone health blood health and
provide antioxidant support and when i
turn 18
all the stuff you need but put yourself
first okay because ritual doesn't stop
there they invented the gold standard
university-led critical trial to prove
the impact of essential for women 18
plus multivitamin
right now ritual is offering my
listeners ten percent off your first
three months visit ritual.com whitney
and turn healthy habits into a ritual
that's you just have to make it a habit
you know a ritual a ritual
that's 10 off at ritual.com whitney you
know i could blather on but you have to
take care of yourself and if you want to
build your business if you want to
you're just got engaged if you want to
find the guy or the woman that you want
whatever it is if you are not taking
care of your body and not being healthy
you're not going to attract something
healthy stop being toxic and just get it
and once you flush those toxins out of
your bod
you can get about of your
brain which is part of your body but i
mean like your emotional toxins science
this podcast is sponsored by better
health
better health will assess your knees and
match you with your own life what's the
point of taking care of your body the
thing that drags your brain around if
your brain is toxic if you're miserable
yeah so true and so that's the thing
it's like you're not gonna put chemicals
in your body you're gonna put toxic
people in your brain toxic thoughts
you're polluting your brain with the
toxic people in your life your toxic
decisions are you addicted to drama are
you addicted to chaos or gambling are
you deading are you overspending to try
to get that hit of adrenaline all this
stuff a better health counselor can help
you figure this out it's not your fault
it's probably inherited ancestral trauma
guilty
none of it's yours go to therapy if
nothing more than to learn that
nothing's your fault that's a great
pitch
you go to therapy so that these better
health counselors say this has nothing
to do with you yep so if nothing else uh
get someone to co-sign on you blaming
your parents for everything even though
you're 40. yeah okay well speak for
yourself you can start communicating in
under 48 hours it's not a crisis line
except when i call it's not self-help it
is professional therapy devices live
securely online if for for nothing else
just someone that will let you just cry
in front of them and they don't jerk off
while you're crying nope they wait till
you hang up special offer for good free
listeners get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
whitney
now back to bridgette i would also
like steal from like the rich girls
houses if they had like a hairbrush or
like
like something i wanted and didn't have
you know and so because i was like you
know where where are you from this was
let's say i was half grew up in
washington dc in georgetown okay and
then half in virginia and i went live
with my aunts and then spent the summers
in west virginia a place called harper's
ferry okay but when i was in miami
[Laughter]
the coal fields
okay it's all coming together
the deep appalachians but yes i went
back and forth from very rural
appalachia to like georgetown dc
and in georgetown i was like similarly
to you we lived in like a like an
apartment in georgia it was around a lot
of very rich people and in dc it was a
lot of diplomats kids i was like the
broke kid at the rich school right and
so
i would go to these girls houses and
they had
tiffany bean necklaces and they had the
j.crew sweaters and the abercrombie and
switch
sweaters and stuff and it was like
because i would read the j crew catalog
and like circle stuff and like like i
remember there's a christmas sweater
there was like wool and i had all these
snowflakes on and it was like 90 dollars
remember when shirts from j crew were 90
yeah they're like 400.
if i didn't go i don't know what
happened but um but like they had all
this stuff and i was the second child
that was the surprise so i only got the
hand-me-downs i never got
new stuff you know i was like i was like
like scribbling in the doc martens with
sharpies to make the black again you
know and so i always wanted just like
new stuff which is so ironic because i
only like vintage trash now but um
that's always like been my thing but i
would i would like steal like a nice
hairbrush and steal a nice because we
had like combs that you like would take
from a hotel
and i remember this girl
she's going to know exactly more
personas
i love how a childhood story you never
just say they're first you can't it's
always and their last name is
it's never just like laura blue yeah or
something like just mine was pretty
boring last name mary murphy oh
it's very
and she yeah well that's very that's
very rhode island yeah that's where
minnesota we moved like every year and a
half but that yeah we were that we were
in private i was in private catholic
school then oh wow
and so she had this hair brush that was
like remember caboodles where you would
put your makeup in a cool noodle
and she just had this hair brush that
was like boodles i've never seen
anything like it it was like a big
square
like horse brush and it was just like
this beautiful brush and i like just put
it in my bag
like i was like i was like just
spreading lice throughout the school
whatever but i just remember
wet bandits yeah i just yeah i just
remember like that i don't know how we
got on this topic but i do want to make
sure oh one more thing i do that is a
shady squirrely thing
tiny thing which is
coming to meet you i'm five minutes away
when i'm not five minutes away that's
like such an la thing though i feel like
oh really i mean i feel like so many
people in l.a are like i'll be right
there there's so many people now they're
sick on recovered alcoholics that won't
fucking get their shit like because it's
it's disrespectful yeah i'm lying i know
well that's my magical thinking too so
the first thing i ask a sponsee always
is if you have something you have
something at four o'clock and it takes
half an hour to get there what time do
you leave
i'm like i'm i'm always early
because i i that's one of my big pet
peeves is when somebody
um
is not i i just feel like time is the
only commodity that we have the true
commodity and so when someone's
disrespectful and i think that's what
you're about to say is like it's a
disrespect for someone's
time
generally so i i try to really i was
also one of those kids that got like
left at school
and would have to wait and i was like i
never want to do that to people but it's
also a respect for yourself because if
so if someone says okay um if you have
to be somewhere at four what time and it
takes half an hour to get there what
time you leave i leave it like four or
ten because you are not in magical
thinking you go life could happen there
could be traffic i may need to stop and
get gas i may have to pee i may have to
get a snack i may run into someone that
i haven't seen in a while like it's in
l.a life could happen you know or just
anywhere you know because the sober
thinking is you can always be 10 minutes
early and sit in your car and catch up
on stuff you know what i mean you can
always be early and make use of that
time whereas when you're in your you
know addictive thinking and not sober
thinking you're like oh i'm going to
subconsciously
like
put myself up against a wall so that i
can get that adrenaline and like be in
the fast in the field like i don't need
to be in a rush but i'm going to put
myself in a situation where i am rushing
and stressed out just because i want
that adrenaline
and then
it's a it's a negative contribution to
my future self because now i'm i'm gonna
feel shame i'm setting myself up for
future shame and i want that shame hit
because that shame hit is gonna justify
that shame driven behavior where i get
to anesthetize then i get to go i left
that interview and i think they hate me
and i just there was a disaster i was
rushed i wasn't thinking and i had to
pee during the whole podcast you know
and it's like well you that's you're not
a victim in this scenario this was all
because you decided you were gonna leave
at 3 30
instead of 310.
this all could have been avoided this
was all a choice you made yeah do you
hear from people who listen that they
struggle with a lot of this kind of
stuff
like the the shame and the self loathing
and yeah huge yeah
and and are the younger women you're
hearing from are they
um
like
depressed or what what's going on with
them here i don't think i could speak
for everyone i think i definitely the
type of people that probably come up to
me and say like you help me with it are
you know a lot of this has been passed
on from generation to generation we're
the first generation of even people
having any modicum of awareness about
any of this or even able to have a
conversation about adrenaline and
dopamine and epigenetic imprinting and
an addiction to adrenaline because
adrenaline turns into dopamine i mean
drama is an addiction yeah and i
inherited it in you know epigenetics of
like any
chemicals that your internal drug
cabinet right your brain so that's the
that's like the difference between um uh
you know
alcoholics are that use substances
versus the alcoholic that uses behavior
in people and sex and love and fantasy
and gambling and deading which are
gnarly as fucking food it's the internal
drug cabinet like i don't need your
outside drugs because i'd rather you
know i can make it myself over here on
your own i can get high
adrenaline turns into dopamine i can
just go cheat i don't need i don't need
your jim beam i'm anorexic that is
calories like you know like it's this is
like i gotta also stay ridiculously
skinny and starving and you know um
uh
hurt myself um so
it i think that this is the first time
this conversation is even which is why
such a big part of like my sponsoring
people and program is about
forgiving uh our parents and because
they did not have tools awareness any of
it i mean we still don't know that much
about the brain you know we pretend we
do but we still don't really know that
much and we're just learning about you
know epigenetic imprinting which is the
chemicals that were emitted when you
were in utero
that what you became addicted to so if
your mom is addicted to crack in utero
then you're gonna be born addicted to
crack or opioids but if your mom when
you were in utero was uh uh producing a
lot of cortisol adrenaline you're gonna
be born addicted to cortisol and
adrenaline i mean even when i was a kid
i was the kid that was like
like i would just throw something just
to get start drama yeah and it and i
think that
you know just that subconscious seeking
of that
you know neurochemical equilibrium that
we inherited is is you know something
that's really
exhausting to have to think about
annoying but
we're the first people that even have
the vocabulary and i'm sure in 10 years
everything we're saying now is going to
be science fiction and debunked but
you know
um
so i think that i do think there's a
little bit of an over correction of
people going like i have depression i
have anxiety and i'm like well you also
might just be 20 well life is a
nightmare that every the language of
therapy is everywhere and it's like if
everything's trauma nothing's trauma if
every so there's again that over there
yeah you should have some anxiety i mean
we might run out of water soon and all
this anxiety that you guys have at that
there might be a fire out there right
now there was an earthquake this morning
and yesterday like all the babies all
like okay no she is like teflon she i
don't yo she doesn't produce adrenaline
or cortisol in 10 years no that's not
what your baby will have water yeah
well you know that i mean i was working
i named her matilda for a reason
i love that name
when i found out what it means i was
like she's gonna need this energy it
means mighty in battle
i love it she's like she just won her
first battle
that's her name but so let me just read
a couple of these laundry list adult
child traits because it's i think
sometimes when i talk about alan on
adult child people like i was very
confused in the beginning too and i was
too embarrassed to ever admit i didn't
know something or ask for help so i'm
just i do want to say before you read
that list one of the things that was so
hard in early sobriety for me
was i felt like um
this giant meh i just kept calling it
the eternal mess i was like oh is this
how i'm gonna feel all the time now just
like meh and my therapist was like
that's called peace i was like oh
it was like my mind exploded when i
heard that because i had never
experienced just emotional
sobriety don't take this the wrong way
but we are like the same person
insult to you compliment to me but that
was the same thing as soon as i got you
know uh in cutting out the toxic people
in my life the the behavior started you
know scheduling things in an emotionally
sober way
and not constantly like you know finding
a way to sleep for four hours and be
murdering mothering micromanaging
obsessing over other people's problems
getting high on other people's drama
i still do this with the gas that's my
one area
where no i am i let my car get down to
like e and i'm like this is
i thought you were a new i huff gas in
the gas station
you're like
dude if it works for you man because
that's what we say when someone's like
no i'm thinking about trying weed again
you're like maybe i'll get this time
like did you go try it oh my god that is
so yes you will rise i still do that but
also it's fucking crazy because you do
know
they account for that
so my brain is like okay if i only have
10 miles left that means i have like 30.
yeah because i know that at the whatever
car
company they're like let's just give it
a little more because we don't want
because we know these people are more
yeah exactly
for the gamblers that's the gambling
addiction though everything kind of not
everything it's a generalization but a
lot of things boil down to gambling
addictions at the end of the day even
like dating young girls when you know
people it's like i got away with 20
let's see if i can get away shoplifting
is the same thing like bargaining bad
bargaining and gambling of like
trying to chase that's my nuts he's like
you are literally like a prepper my and
i am i'm like a prepper in every way and
that's like the worst way not to be a
property you should always have a full
tank of gas but it's like let me just
get this fucking adrenaline let me
self-sabotage i still need to feel alive
somehow yeah but it's but my yeah
but um georgia said to me uh uh she was
like um i was like i don't know i'm just
like
bored all the time she's like that's not
that's just called serenity because i
was just so
my baseline
my piece was i feel alive in the time of
crisis like crisis is where i felt
because when things are placid and quiet
and peaceful that to me means that
the damocles sword is tongue i'm wearing
them as earrings like the shoe's gonna
drop and yeah when things are calm
that's when i'm panicked because then
things are gonna go wrong when things go
wrong i'm like
you got that i got this because like the
shoe dropped i don't worry about the
shoe drop are you good in crisis
excellent like are you the person yeah
my cousin always makes fun of me she's
like whenever there's a crisis like this
she's like i go
we went to the movies she's like i come
out bridget's got an old lady's head in
her hand this old lady fell and
everyone's around her and i'm ordering
people around i'm like when that shit
hits the span things get so quiet i'm
not the one that's going to show up to
the baby shower and know how to talk to
your college friends i'm going to be the
one
so how's your marriage yeah but when
they're woolsey fires i drove into the
fires like yeah it was like i was like
everyone's tweeting about and i was just
driving over down power lines and i was
just like it's a total yeah it's like
when someone's child gets kidnapped i'm
like i got it like that literally
happened with a friend a friend of mine
but
she's like emily she's like no but she's
exactly but she's like i can't get you
to like show up to my kids first
birthday party i'm like if one of the
kids falls out of a tree i'm your guy
yeah but just chilling talking about i
always say that i'm like i'm not gonna
remember your birthday but i'll drive
you to chemo like a hundred percent
um
just little things because it's i feel
like sometimes this is not it's coming
off like slightly vague uh
these are traits that you would have if
you were grew up now alcoholic home
which could mean chaotic dysfunctional
mental
mental illness uh someone being just
physically ill like just something that
i don't know i think the most um
traumatized children are the ones that
grew up in a quote unquote happily
married
when i when someone's like yeah my
parents have been married 40 years i'm
like that sounds toxic
like that's why i'm like oh my god
that sounds really
really sick all those like normal people
with good boundaries i know came from
like good yeah yeah yeah
and that
and none of the people who so my guy uh
that i'm dating now he his parents uh
have been together his whole life and
every time we fight about the tiny thing
about all right then i'll fucking get
the fuck out like the tiniest thing yeah
i'm like it's he's like no you stay in
the room yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's like it was like oh you want
me to be on time then why don't you just
fucking leave because i don't need this
it's just like the littlest thing
will make me blow up the entire
relationship and he's like no like
you work through things and then you're
like get back together and like this
happens a lot like everything is the
last straw for me because i so okay
being alone and i spent so much time
being alone um
but anyway um enough about my awesome
choices uh laundry list 14 traits of
adult child one we became isolated and
afraid of people and authority figures i
mean before i was in program authority
figures i was just like
ugh like just like
terrified of criticism
i would walk into a room which we're
kind of wired to do humans are wired to
walk into a room and rank ourselves
which is part of the reason why social
media is so toxic for us because usually
we're following people that are a higher
ranking than we are and we're designed
to uh uh move into uh a situation and go
okay who's the top tier where am i i'm
not the alpha i'm not the beta am i the
omega am i the sigma am i like when
there's a fire who do i follow and who's
asked do i need to kiss basically to
stay in the good graces of this tribe we
are wired for that on some level um but
when you're on instagram you're
constantly following you know kylie
jenner and billy eilish you're
constantly just the lowest of the totem
pole which makes
your primordial reptilian brain kind of
think like oh i'm the lowest ranking i
have the lowest status of anyone in this
but that's not your tribe it's an
illusion you know yeah but i would move
into a room and just go like whose ass
do i need to kiss
to
talk to to make myself think i'm not a
total piece of garbage and it would just
be like how do i get that
and like studying like what do i need to
do to get that person's attention just
like
it was just like a stretch it was like a
i couldn't just like hang out it was
everything was like
a survival opportunity yeah yeah you
know what i mean and it's also just
being able to kind of evaluate those
pecking orders and i i know i got that
without even trying just for moving a
lot i just i don't realize i do it but i
walk into a room and i'm like i know who
to talk to and you're trying to
ultimately you're just trying to make
yourself safe and i think it again like
uh something that i lost my train of
thought on before all of the
the
the our character defects the things
that we don't like about that we're both
talking about these are all tools that
did work at some point
now they're just obsolete like yeah
they're like that that like buddhist
cohen that's like about the guy who used
carried the boat to cross the river and
then kept carrying the boat
or the guy was like why are you doing
this i bring this up all the time the
guy that um the japanese the soldier in
world war ii that went into a cave and
no one told him the war was over and for
30 years they found him and he you know
it's like we're all just shadow boxing
trying to fight war you know it does
feel like me sometimes yeah where you're
just like i have all these incredible
tools to fight the super dangerous war
you're telling me i don't need any of
them anymore you know it's like you know
taking things out of your backpack or
you know just obsolete tools it's like
it and i look at them i try to number
one anthropomorphize them like it's like
you know my perfectionism is like like i
call him marvin sometimes where i'm like
you i really needed you when i was young
and people needed me to be perfect
because i was a mistake i have to talk
to them and go like
thank you i know you're just trying to
help but i don't need you anymore
this is no longer serving me you're
actually a liability like i can hang you
up like
in the in in terms of the weapons i
needed you're like a musket
yeah i don't need this anymore you know
what i'm saying like you're just
obsolete but it's hard to
be able to give that stuff up without um
like uh
having to be mad at them like why like
jealousy or what are like just these
these uh maladaptive behaviors
micromanaging people pleasing
shape-shifting it's like thank you i
needed you at some point but i just
don't anymore do you think that we ever
get over it or does it just you know my
husband and i were talking about this
about prejudices
there's this great therapist who says
most of growing up and being an adult is
like rearranging your prejudices so that
they
it's like are we really evolving or are
we just like rearranging your presence
that's interesting i think it depends on
the kind of work you put in and like
whether you're a cd or no
how do you know and like there's some
times that like
change with me will come very slow and
there's times i have like huge spurts in
a small amount of time because either
i'm
something magical happens or
uh like when my dad died it was just
like all of a sudden
all this shit crystallized overnight
yeah like all these like toxic
relationships are like ah this is a bad
i should probably get out of this i just
never texted the person back again i
never thought about it yeah it was like
sometimes there's like something you
know losing our friend bob saget like a
couple things i was struggling with just
like
it was just over like like over
committing was done
yeah literally
as soon as saggett died i was like nope
i can't do that
why not i don't want to yeah no shame no
people pleasing like sometimes when real
problems
happen all the little fake problems in
your head all of a sudden are like oh
okay we have perspective now so i think
you know big cataclysmic events can can
cause uh not that i recommend uh them to
anyone they can cause like a very
exponential little spurt of growth yeah
when you think you're not growing or a
pandemic can happen or getting pregnant
and having a child i mean i see it in
the quality of my relationships too like
family and close friends and
also just maintaining this i remember
even in early sobriety there was a time
where i was trying to promote all these
female comics and i had i was like
trying to support them and
um
and i realized that
i wanted so badly for them to be my
friends but there was not really any
reciprocity and i was like maybe if i
stop they'll call me and i know you get
less funny you're about to funny
i just i realized i was like why am i
investing in the in these relationships
where there's not any reciprocity why am
i chasing the approval of people that
are mentally ill i just wanted friends
yeah you know and i i think that getting
sober was weird too because i didn't
have
um i lost my party friends yeah and then
when you get healthy the sick and angry
it just was weird and then i didn't know
and i wanted to just be like cool with
my peer comedy peers and then it ended
up
um i just was like i'm investing in this
thing these things that aren't it's not
reciprocal and i want relationships that
are quality where i feel like even if i
don't have that many many people in my
life at least and i see it even like
relationships with my family that my
siblings and parents and
even just having like a healthy
relationship with my husband at the
moment you know i mean 10 years from now
i might watch this and be like well
who knows but at the moment being it's
so
easy like i've never been in a
relationship that's not just up and down
and dysfunctional and manipulative and
shady and
um
now just being in something that's so
loving and tender that's what it that's
like crazy to me tenderness because i'm
so
i'm like you i'm like oh i guess i'm
moving to sri lanka then yeah yeah fine
i guess i'm gonna fuck your brother
tonight i will go so nuclear so fast
because the fear of getting hurt is so
intense i will hurt you before you hurt
me any day of the week and i will go low
like i will if you do the tiniest bit of
superficial damage
i will do
molecular damage of like and you've
never given me an orgasm i mean i will
go make it irreparable so there's no
coming
yeah it sports earth and like the
relationship i'm in now is the first
time i don't i realize like on a
cellular level before i used to be able
to know it on a conscious level but i
didn't have the default wiring built up
yet of if i win we both lose so if i'm
trying to win an argument it already
inherently means we're on different
sides and i truly don't want to hurt you
like i truly
don't
want to cause damage because i respect
you too much because i'm with someone
finally that is so
formidable in terms of his character
that i don't even try to manipulate you
because because also so many
relationships i was in for a longest
time we don't realize that when we're
presenting these false selves and we're
ourselves
and we're manipulating people to want to
be with us whether we're pretending to
be a certain person or pretending to you
know act like this or believe this or
subscribe to this or wear this kind of
makeup or shape shift then the
relationship you can get it but then
you'll always doubt while they're there
yeah and you're like well the only
reason this person loves me is because i
pretended to be the person i'm not so
because i sort of
the confluence of like all the work i've
done and the pandemic where i was just
kind of like
like relentlessly authentic because we
all just got a little raw we met during
the pandemic so he just saw the worst
side of me up front
so i didn't present this false bullshit
self so now i don't have to live in the
shame of well now i'm being who i am and
you just wanted me to be that person i
pretended to be what's going on with you
that you fell for it yeah you know what
i mean because that's the thing is when
you manipulate someone
uh it undermines yourself you get them
but then you lose respect for them
because you fucking fell for that isn't
that the irony of like when you cheat on
someone you lose respect for them
because you're like you don't know i'm
cheating on you
you're fucking pathetic like you're
buying this bullshit like you're
believing my lies like
like it's just the sick like so i don't
have any of that and um that's like
being the other woman you're just
undermining your faith in men every time
you do it wild you know you're like oh
all these men are assholes well maybe
stop
sleeping with married men yeah
yeah you're seeking the very data
yeah like you're creating the data
for yourself
whatever you go or you look like exactly
like you're the person that is creating
the data that this stereotype is based
on yeah like so if you just stopped
doing it that wouldn't be a stereotype
in the first place
uh laundry list 14 traits of adult child
we became approval seekers and lost our
identity in the process three we became
frightened by angry people and any
personal criticism four we either became
alcoholics marry them or both or find
other compulsive personalities such as a
workaholic to fulfill our sick
abandonment needs dude the first time i
went to a workaholic anonymous meeting
it was the funniest shit ever well i
only went to one a workaholic anonymous
meeting first of all showed up everyone
was like 30 minutes late oh really yep
it was like five of us and it was like
some hollywood people that were
kind of like successful known people and
it was wild cause when we were all met
we're like i love your work no i don't i
mean don't work more i mean just it was
like this really weird and then at the
end of 12-step meetings you say it works
if you work it and you're worth it but
you're not allowed to say work oh we are
so it was like
what was it it was
god grant with the serenity accept the
things i cannot change the courage to
change the things i can't and the wisdom
to know the difference
and then the end was you're worth it and
you're fabulous
and i was like it works if you work and
i was like you're not allowed to say
that here
and it was it was people that like
would like someone was like a small
business owner and she would like leave
in the middle of the night and go back
to work while her wife was sleeping to
go like do stuff there was someone that
was addicted to crafting
um
it was just like a fascinating you know
i went to a marijuana anonymous one
meeting
um and everyone was late
the share there's no timer on the shares
which drove me insane
okay normally you time shares they're
like like like two minutes with one
minute to ride five minutes of wine
that's really long but they they exist
but there's no timer and the snacks were
amazing i was like this is that is so
funny exactly what i would expect of
this
and it like went over it was like oh we
finished when we finished i'm like that
is so funny such a marijuana like mma
meeting that i would expect it was just
that dude
you know what meeting has the best
snacks
overeaters anonymous
it's always such a thing it's the snack
for always
such a thing because how do you deal
with that i've only i've only went to a
couple
like it was just you know
it's actually more like the immature
person like me being like really guys
like we've got like you know the
illustrator fat free potato chips or the
over here like it's just sort of like
because every food is someone's trigger
food like so the person that brings the
snacks at the overeaters anonymous
meaning some of them have rules that
there's no snacks restful a lot of times
there's no snacks like at some specific
studies i would just imagine like celery
carrot sticks so funny maybe not even
carrot sticks just celery and cucumber
yeah or it's like they go the other way
because they're like like locked you
should be able to have one like a lot of
it is like pre-portioned you know like
the pre-portioned pretzel packs i never
read 100 calories consider this speaking
i never even considered this how
what a like hard thing to navigate that
would be such a mind fuck you're like
hey you newcomer you're in charge of the
snacks she brings like a pound cake
uh five we live from the viewpoint of
victims and are attracted by that
weakness and our love and friendship
relationships we
love being a victim and we will make
ourselves a victim in any situation we
have an overdeveloped sense of
responsibility it's easier easier for us
to become concerned with others rather
than ourselves this enables us not to
look too closely at our own faults etc
over developed sense of responsibility
whitneycummings.com
we get guilt feelings when we stand up
for ourselves instead of giving in to
others so
we call after burn if when you do say no
you're like why did i do that i
shouldn't have done that why did i why
didn't i just fucking do it why didn't i
just fucking do it i could have said yes
just like if we are able to stand up
this the guilt just which is ancestral
it's inherited guilt is a system that
controls family it might be the system
that your mom used to control you okay
so you're gonna go stay at your friend's
house till midnight okay fine i'll just
be here a lot like just
our parents got it honestly
but guilt is a big way to control people
guilting people and shaming people and
then we actually and guilt is you know
i've heard said like the most useless
emotion like it doesn't really
like i built this business because i
felt guilty like there's no i saved this
like it's just
like
it's just something that i think shame
serves an important purpose in society
but
uh and we have to have some shame so we
don't act selfishly all the time but
guilt is something that is just not
particularly productive yeah my
therapist always says unless it's
it's
like in
motivating you to take a different
action
it's useless
we became addicted to excitement
we confuse love and pity and we tend to
love quote people we can pity and rescue
we have stuffed our feelings from
traumatic childhoods and have lost the
ability to feel or express our feelings
because it hurts too much denial this
also
to me was what i call like emotional
dyslexia of like when things were
like sad situations i always was like
making inappropriate jokes and laughing
and then when
things were
ostensibly
fun it always felt like work so i'm like
being at parties i was like i feel like
i'm pretending i'm having fun at a party
like you know what i mean like i just
when other people were having fun i was
always like
i don't know how to do fun this is
stressful to me this seems to be so easy
for all you guys but i'm like just
trying to figure out how to make you
like me and you know a lot of people i
think would label that as like social
anxiety or whatever but
we've already kind of talked about this
but i was like
dark shit made me laugh yeah
and
fun shit made me uncomfortable when you
kind of
self-identify as a narcissist is it
something that you've been diagnosed
with or is it like the inherited
narcissism from family is this is this
like
clinical narcissism or is it something
that
is just a trait you inherited
did you just diagnose me as a narcissist
no you always say my narcissism you're
like as a narcissist
no because you said you said this it's
almost like a trap yeah
that you that if you say
so from what i understand about
narcissism which i've unfortunately i i
do think i know uh
as much as there is to know because i
was raised around that and my biggest
fear in life is that i am one yeah
but from what i understand is that if
you are able to
say to your therapist am i a narcissist
you inherently can't be one because an
actual narcissist could never comprehend
it would be too annihilating to their
fragile ego to acknowledge that they had
any flaws because i say this all the
time and my therapist is like
i'm like am i a narcissist
you inherently can't be one already but
she said because if you come from like a
family system where there's narcissism
an actual the narcissistic personality
disorder
um you will inherit traits that are
narcissistic you'll take on some of
those characteristics sure i'm sure of
course as you will any
there are the traits of people that are
insecure whatever your if your that was
an our sister mom wasn't you'll take on
hers too that totally makes sense but
also from what i understand in terms of
narcissism there's a really good article
i think it was in the atlantic about
this about how um
narcissists are all very different
because it's based on
uh what your parents would have approved
of so narcissists aren't at five years
old trying to get the approval of
twitter and stuff they only are trying
to get the approval of their primary
caretakers so it's everyone's narcissist
is specific about their primary
caretakers would have wanted their child
to be so you can be super narcissistic
about like i'm the best athlete i'm the
best football player it's like oh your
dad wanted you to be an athlete um you
know or you can be like i'm the smartest
person in the fucking room i'm the
funniest person oh your parents valued
funny yeah so
people are gonna be narcissistic and
different or i'm like the hottest
fucking thing like i am like fucking a
10 and i'm you know whatever if it's
about your appearance you're like oh
your mom wanted you to be hot yeah and
was disappointed that you were ugly so
you're projecting the image that your
parents would have approved of because
it's the only way for you to uh
be able to delude yourself into
believing that your primary caretakers
loved you because otherwise it would be
too damaging and you would just blow
your brains out because you have to
basically project the image as a way to
get love and safety because children
can't live without their parents
protection and approval you project
the false self that your parent the
identity that your parents would have
approved of and then you move on in life
and you continue to do that because my
therapist was saying too like
statistically we we throw that term
around a lot about people and exes but
she's like it's a very small percentage
that's actually
narcissistic personality disorder like
way smaller than you would a lot of us
need to just go he was a narcissist so
that we don't have to own our part of
the relationship so a lot of times we're
like well he was a narcissist or she was
a fucking psycho it's like well chances
are
you had a part two but if it's easier to
just diagnose this person as a
narcissist and do it and we do live in a
very narcissistic culture it's like
everywhere
yeah which is i think we always have
like i i'm big on like everything we
have today we've always had in some
iteration it just like kind of looked
different but
you know that might just be like a
comedy generalization that you know um
but okay we judge ourselves harshly and
have very low self-esteem we're
dependent personalities who are
terrified of abandonment will do
anything to hold on to a relationship in
order to not experience the painful
abandonment feelings which we received
from living with sick people who were
never there emotionally for us
alcoholism is a family disease we became
para alcoholics and took on the
characteristics of that disease even
though we did not pick up the drink para
alcoholics are reactors rather than
actors so i do think a lot of traits
that that masquerade as as narcissism
are probably
rooted in
like
codependence right and
people causing it's a very narcissistic
disease to be like well i'm gonna rescue
you and save you yeah because
you're not capable of doing yourself and
i'm perfect you know so it's like i
think you could be narcissistic and not
maybe necessarily a narcissist right
right that's what i was wondering that's
probably
maybe the answer yeah
no i that's what i was wondering is i i
mean because i know people who have been
diagnosed borderline and that's really
hard like that's real though that's
right that's real but it's hard and
having to be able to have that
self-awareness of when you're
when you're in that it's like how do you
get outside of the matrix of your own
mind so borderlines from what i
understand
um is
is you know borderlines whereas someone
that's you know maybe bipolar or a
narcissist they can
fake being a victim in order to
manipulate you right whereas a
borderline
truly feels the pain
so
borderline comes from so there's a great
book if you think that you might have a
borderline in your life which if you
have a pit in your stomach all the time
around someone
and you're walking on eggshells a lot
there's a great book called i i hate you
don't leave me is one and walking on
eggshells how to live with someone or be
around someone that does borderline
personality disorder because
when
you set a boundary or take care of
yourself usually they interpret it as a
criticism or as an attack
and whereas a narcissist or a psychopath
or sociopath might be might be um
masquerading as being a victim
borderlines actually had some kind of
horrible trauma happen to them and they
feel it so
borderlines and also because they
actually were victims they're not
pretending like it comes from trauma
it's not something you're born with uh
whereas like a lack of empathy as a
psychopath and a sociopath you're born
with a brain wiring and it's that like
very black or white like will split put
you on a pedestal and then like kick you
out but you lack compunction but it's
true the dopamine you're not you're
getting dopamine from someone else being
in pain like that right mental illness
whereas like whereas so is borderline
but it's something that is is all most i
mean look you can argue everything's
nature and nurture but it is mostly
nurture it's like coming from someone
was molested they were abused and are
borderline but they actually feel the
feelings you can't argue with someone's
feelings you know whereas a lot of
people can i can pretend you hurt me
just to fucking win this argument right
and that's just an asshole or
unrecovered not sober prison but a
borderline person like they even say
like if someone's borderline
you shouldn't tell them they're
borderline right because it actually
just makes things worse because then
they're like well i'm borderline and i
was it just
it's like a fucking
sorry i'm trying to not say chinese
finger trap um but it's just a fucking
rat fuck
has that book not been cancelled it's
not about guns
so yeah i hope i didn't go too hard do
you ever feel like because one of the
big things in program rooms which
12-step programs i know a lot every
meeting you go to
some are great some suck some it does it
depends like that's why they say take
what you like and leave the rest a lot
of people that are in program room are
fucking crazy i've got my phone stolen
at a 12-step room there's a lot of
creeps like it's not like anyone that's
in a 12-step room my therapist always
goes hot not hotbeds of mental health
yeah it's just like there's some people
that are awesome and some people that
are really treacherous and
yes like i mean you've seen fight club
like helena bottom carter she was
addicted to 12-step meetings and she
would go she was like the creep that
would just go to 12-step meetings like
pray you know in l.a there's always like
scientology people praying on 12-step
like the om people the orgasmic
meditation there there's a while where
they were creeping around that's wild i
hate that shit i don't even know what
that is nothing that sounds like some
shit there's just nothing more
disgusting than trolling an aaa meeting
for a 12-step meeting for anything yeah
like whether it's a date or we call it
13 stepping whereas like if you're a
newcomer
someone that has been in program will
use their power to go like can i help
you and manipulate you like that's how i
got my husband
[Music]
and sometimes it's how you meet your
soul mate yeah um
and so it is what it is
yeah i my whole thing was like
anyone in this room is my hero and i
took my therapist like there's a lot of
fucking crazy people
in those meetings and i'm like but
they're all in an abandoned gymnasium at
7 30 on a tuesday night how could any of
these people not have their shit
together they're like it's the island of
misfit toys and totally
you can definitely because we we're down
one person so because of sammy flaps and
folds the conspiracy one she she has
some personal stuff going on so she'll
be out for like a while i think a couple
weeks what what constitutes personal
stuff i don't want to set the precedent
here the thing is that it's personal
good for you but i just want to make
sure it's not smashing it on a podcast
that's not what professional people do
she has cancer right
um
i would love to come on and um and
watkins yeah i would love that yeah
i i think i want to do dumpster fire
first though okay i'm a true fan because
the jokes on dumpster fire are fucking
it is very rare that i can laugh if
something's
if another community writes something
funny i'll mostly get jealous but if i
can actually
overcome the jealousy with just laughing
at it when you were talking about um
the sort of like left-wing hypocrites
that have like yachts with their
environmentalists yeah and like you know
and they're flying private and
about like they're gonna start naming
their yachts in the uss greta
just like
like there's no extent to how ironic
this gets um okay love you don't read
elephants the best
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
you